the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club get your fill of world class Chess
at the sinkfield cup in St Louis with
the standings all tied up the table was
set for someone to carve out an early
lead for themselves a well-rested
Richard Rapport was ready to feast in
his return to the board but he went home
hungry as the game fizzled into a draw
thankfully for those celebrating pieces
were gobbled up quickly as the remaining
games equalized allowing players to
enjoy the remainder of the holiday a
leader has yet to emerge who will get on
a roll and break away from the group
round four of exciting chess coming up
[Music]
next
welcome to round four of the sinkfield
cup we are here at the cuuk where you
can find the best chess merchandise and
we have the best chess players competing
upstairs let's go back to the studio and
follow the
action welcome to St Louis the home of
Chess in America as the St Louis chess
club proudly presents the sinkfield cup
we are nearly halfway and still looking
for a leader and it all starts right
now hello and welcome it is round four
of the Singo Cup and the chess Gods seem
to be favoring balance and equilibrium
as all the players have played their
games out to a draw but will today be
the day when it all changes we'll find
out I'm International master ianka
housea and it's a great pleasure to be
here as always alongside two very fine
Grand Masters yes a sah
and Peter smidler to be here be a
pleasure pleasure and I I like the look
I don't I like I like it clean shaving
hello everybody and welcome to our show
well it's been a draw fill desert and
your commentators are struggling but
fortunately we have been forged in the
fires of commentary ovens we have a
nine-time British champion an eight time
Russian Champion a four time American
champion we can do it we can turn the
the show into an entertainment dream Joy
do the honors and tell us about the
standings absolutely is my guy
winning your guy is winning also my guy
is winning and Peter's guy is winning
Anastasia everyone's a winner basically
but to take a look at this these are the
standings Fabiana Carana because of his
high rating he's at the top Ali Resa fou
as well everyone has drawn their games
and just to remind everyone that Yan
Kristoff Duda did withdraw after round
two because of ill health and his game
against Anish giri has been voided so
everything's still to play for and tell
us about the format for this year's
singfield cup yes it is a nplayer round
robin and the players will be playing at
the classical time control of 90 minutes
for the first 40 moves and then there
will be a 30 minute time bonus for the
rest of the game and a 30C increment
from move one and the best part no draw
offers allowed and a standard Point
scoring system of one point for the win
half point for a draw and our schedule
JY yes so the players are playing one
game per day but it is a very hard
fought very tense and we're now on round
four Friday November the 24th otherwise
known as Black Friday but the players
will be playing all the way through to
November the 30th and be mind on rest
day is on Sunday November 26th looking
forward to it thank you Joe and Peter
again I love the look I like the clean
shave uh break down uh some of the
statistics let's look uh for for a
culprit here uh with 12 uh 12 draws out
of 12 so far we uh have a nice spread of
openings as you will see on your screen
right now but they can't really be
blamed as you will as you will see on
this graphic we have uh three games
played with the R Lopez we had two
Sicilians two pets which could perhaps
be somewhat to blame and five five other
games were uh featured all separate
openings but with Spanish and Sicilian
featuring being featured in five out of
12 those are the two most fighting
openings there there is so hardly
anything here suggests we should have
the the drought that we've had so far
right and the drought it has been as you
will see uh in a moment uh this is the
by now Infamous graphic of what was to
be expected from the previous 10
editions of the singfield cup with a
statistical
uh probabilities of a uh decisive game
uh in each round we've had three two of
the higher uh rated rounds and round
three was slightly lower but still on
the high side and as for the actual uh
decisive percentage it's down there at
the bottom it's the X uh X X's uh we're
at 0% so far uh hard to say what causes
this and of course every day we we come
here freshly hoping for uh for decisive
game perhaps today will be our day uh
and enough about the Doom and Gloom
let's brighten all of our days by
introducing woman Grand Master Anastasia
Carlovich uh good morning
n good morning Peter hello yaser and
yovanka and hello everyone I'm here for
you not far away from the plane when
you're waiting for the players to come
and share their thoughts after the games
I will also take care with I will I will
take care of social media accounts of
grand CH Stant and lose chess club along
with uh beim toov who is also working
here at the plain venue uh yesterday we
had Thanksgiving and thanks to the
organizers of the tournament everyone
was invited for the dinner and you can
see the backstage video which I took uh
just from the restaurant of the hotel
the chase where the all participants are
staying and you can see also our crew
who also had this nice dinner ala fuja
um you could say also Chief Arbiter or
sorry chief commentor yaser sarahan um
and we got this very nice comment that
my life goal to be at the dinner table
with yaser San I can tell you it's an
experience for sure and the only problem
is when you sit with yaser his stories
are so funny that sometimes you forget
to eat that's the only problem on this
note let me bring it to yaser maybe it's
a time yaser to to arrange a dinner for
your fans I was think about it sounds
sounds great to me my only question is
who's cooking
but figure me in I'm ready to go uh Joy
uh set the plates and tell our viewers
what they can expect for the pairings
for this round four very exciting it is
nonetheless very exciting because we
have Anish giri remember he is playing
for a spot in the 2024 candidates he
will play off against Maxim vasher lra
giri needing a good performance at this
event Nashi is playing Pano car for me
that's a marquee match up right there
twice Challenger versus single
Challenger Fabby that's got to be that's
going to be big we have Wesley so
against Richard report remember
yesterday Richard some disappointedly
left the game with a draw today he might
be out there looking for revenge and Ali
Resa fua against Dominguez and here we
are back in the playing Hall and we see
the players going through the security
checks and there we see Fabiano Marana
walking to his game I think that's the
first time I've seen Chris bird the
Arbiter wearing a t-shirt and not his
habitual suit and jacket I mean the
Arbiters are always you know they're
supposedly uh very well-dressed Peter I
mean come on they have to keep up the
stand I think even the Arbors are in on
the let's change something up and hope
it produces a decisive game band wagon
as as you can see here exactly and uh
the players are are fighting hard Joy I
mean regardless of the results it's not
a joke
uh there have been some great fights
what are they fighting absolutely and uh
you can see it's a huge pot of money
$100,000 for first place as well as
grandchester points of 12 if it's tied
13 someone wins outright second place
$65,000 thirdd Place 48,000 and there
are prizes for everyone and the Grand's
chest T points up for grabs uh getting
into the bonus pool of the top three you
can earn bonus monies and so uh the
fight for the GCT tour as well as the
Grand Prix the ELO ratings uh players
have a lot to fight for in this
competition for because candidate spots
essentially are up for grabs and Peter I
want to join you bring have you join
that conversation because for me uh the
the ELO and inviting the highest rated
player to the candidates that makes
perfect sense but I always thought of it
as being a formula not one single
waiting list as we've discussed
previously on the show for both of us
this has been a bit of a shock that they
they are only using one list one list
and it's the December it's the end of
January the 1 January highest rating on
January the 1st will get that spot for
the candidates tournament 2024 happening
in Toronto and as you can see the live
rating there
2761 an giri 25 27454
52 yeah and I think just off screen just
off screen ler Dominguez is not very far
off from this picture as well he might
be two points behind Wesley if I
remember correctly so yeah this is they
need to start winning games obviously
for this for this to start shaking up
further but uh it's incredibly close
with many of these players not playing
any more classical chess until uh that
all important January 1 rating list
exactly as you see the players getting
started we're the lady in red and we've
got a
hoodie for Ali Raza I love the game
let's start with Fabby uh because he's
our grand chest tour leader and I see
Yan and fabbi as being our Marquee
matchup again uh these gentlemen know
each other well from the candidates uh
tournament events uh Yan has become the
Challenger to the world champion Magnus
at the time twice
Bobby a single time so I see these two
guys have having a rivalry that is uh
well uh a good one E2 E3 uh nimso Indian
on the board now uh when I was playing
the white side of the Nimo Indian I
always liked the move Queen C2 a move
favored by Kappa Blanca became known as
the classical the E3 I've always
associated with the Kea Rubenstein the
Rubenstein uh uh variation the idea Kea
prized the two Bishops and he wants to
win this dark Square Bishop by
encouraging ex exchange just didn't want
the double Pawn so he would play Knight
E2 and A3 here we have a modern-day
treatment it is very much very much a
modern day treatment which when I
realized this this has become
fashionable I remember it was really a
shock to for me because this is sort of
how you might react to the nzo you know
no theory about the Nimo at all and you
worried about doubling the the pawns on
C3 and you make this very passive
looking move Bishop G2 allowing black
wide variety of structures very often
these days black do play uh D7 D5 here
but other things are also available uh
but this has become very very uh
mainstream and a lot of very strong
players are playing precisely this
simply the explanation is very simple
there are more challenging uh ways to uh
play against IMO but they have been
analyzed into dust in particular I think
for many many years the move Queen C2
exact has been the central focal point
of uh theoretical discussions against
the Nimo but I think it's very well
established that if black knows what
they're doing here uh they'll be fine
and in fact I was going as you as you
were giving the speech about the the
Rubenstein approach against Animo I was
going to say all kinds of zish adjacent
nimos have are very much coming back
into into fashion and I was wondering if
Yan is going to play A3 here and go for
these positions because they uh while
they are strategically very very risky
with the uh C3 C4 complex becoming an
actual weakness uh they do provide for
very very sharp games uh quite often and
uh the choice between let's say A3 and
Bishop D2 here is a very polarizing
choice because one is a mess very often
a huge mess with a very sharp very
tactical play and Bishop D2 normally
leads to to a more restrained uh kind of
a game D5 played by Fabiano in response
exactly uh are you a nimso player for
either side JY do you like no but I have
dabbled in this variation as white black
as white with Bishop D2 with Bishop D2
the and I remember it was uh a trendy
thing back then it was 2020 2021 but I
wasn't really getting that much from the
opening I mean I saw some games with
mishy Anan playing you know just
capturing the porn in the middle and
then trying to put a knight onto E5 but
we will see how this game develops and
there we see A3 being played attacking
the bishop um one of the things as black
that I I sought to do in these nimzo
Indians I do appreciate he could go back
Bishop E7 uh is to try to trade some of
the minor pieces off the board with
takes on C3 takes on C3 Knight E4 now
you're welcome to play Bishop B4 but I
fear I feel that after Bishop before
Rook uh A8 you're going to have to do
something contorted to avoid
a very possibly and I think if you
choose to do that which uh uh Fabby
already declined to do you have to play
I think in spirits after something like
Rook C1 here or quein C2 you can choose
either of those two moves I suspect it's
very uh similar in spirit to like the
old Lasker laska variation of the queen
G declined which is not everybody stays
because you're absolutely fighting for
two results there will never be any I
mean white could really misplay it later
but you're declaring from very early on
that you're only trying to equalize
whereas Bishop B7 very much leaves the
game uh as open yeah as played Knight F3
and Knight B7 played by F very quickly
unsurprisingly F comes quite well
prepared against this line it is a very
uh topical line these days yeah I for me
you know help me out here guys I'm
looking at this position I'm thinking
for me the reason why I might you know
Rah rahah cheer the fact that my Bishop
is on D2 is that I could play
C5 now normally speaking after for
example C6 I just put a move on the
board uh normally speaking after C6
Bishop D3 B6 B4 A5 I have to worry about
the fact that my Rook on A1 is
undefended but in this case taada thank
to the bishop being on D2 uh I don't
have to worry and I could I could try to
get something on the queen side is this
in the spirit of Bishop D2 Peter I'm not
sure I mean C5 is playable but uh first
off even the line that you were showing
these types of positions have been known
to be pretty even let's say we play sure
H3 A5 even let's say we somehow managed
to convince black to play Bishop A6 and
we take on A6 and one move right uh
let's not do that it's not really that
important for me to look for a waiting
move here this is a very well wellknown
structure which you normally get with
the bishop with a bishop on F4 there is
a lot of
theory uh connected with this structure
specifically starting from this position
right C5 C6 and so on and we very soon
let me actually illustrate so that we
can compare two positions properly this
is all very theoretical very very
wellknown
line so there is this position which you
get in the Queen's gam declined and then
there is this position with the bishop
on D which we can get which we can get
in the game if uh Yan were to choose C5
it's very very important it's not
inspiring really is very very important
to to have it outside the chain and
actually participating in the game this
I think is very comfortable for black
immediately so I think it's
understandable that Yan prefers to keep
things uh T and just goes Queeny to now
que queency 2 isn't the most popular
move and I I remember remember looking
at this position and going for the porn
takes porn plans uh the Carl's Bad
structures with structure and eventually
putting a knight onto E5 like early or
with or without Bishop to D3 tting a
bishop D3 yeah so and then kind of a
Pillsbury attack with 95 castles and
perhaps after C5 you could consider
taking with the Knight as well to
perhaps take some of the sting out of
those plans with Knight F5 and F4 but
yeah it's a very in that particular case
though Peter then I can again maybe I
can find reason to take pride in the
move Bishop to D2 could I play Knight C3
and if we were to trade the bishop is
yay and this now looks like it was a
quein Indian only the pawn is on not on
B6 and on B7 it looks like a petan
quin's Indian now yeah and yeah you can
absolutely imagine white being slightly
better in a position like this I'm still
reminded of your Abracadabra the bishop
was on G3 you wanted to put it on C3 AB
Joy I got the bishop on C3 cheer me on
yeah I'm I'm fa no actually I'm a favor
of the bishop coming to this particular
Square in this particular porn structure
I mean you even see it I think in
grunfeld lines when the bishop comes to
D2 and yeah that's right it's a nice
piece there well let's go around the
horn and see what we have we have a game
between Anish giri and Vella looks like
a Queen's Gambit accepted Peter and I
have have to say
mvl uh leaving the territory of the
groomfield uh defense as and
specifically becoming a qga player yeah
Queen game B accepted is especially yeah
you know what quite interesting most of
the games in this tournament has been
starting with E4 E5 and then suddenly
everyone has kind of said well we need
change now trying is it the day of it is
I believe we've had eight out of 12 so
far seven we saw on our screen and there
was at least one Italian that didn't
make it to that graphic so at least
eight out of 12 where W E4 games and
today zero out of 12 and yeah this is a
very classical quin's Gambit accepted
which featured a very weird kind of a
two-step here Anish played Rook e one
which is a topical little move uh aiming
to to go for E4 E5 breaks as early as
possible to which mvl replied with
Bishop B7 maybe not the most obvious
move but perfectly playable move and
then you said okay I'm I'm very happy
with this we are now going to play the D
dc5 lines and interestingly in response
there is obviously the option of
transposing to one of the main positions
of the DT C5 line but mvl says no I will
take with the bishop on C5 and I will
say that your Rook on E1 is at least not
an improvement over the Rook on F1 if
you want to give me a check on D1 I will
put the King on E7 and this is an extra
Tempo and as for the comparison normally
of course you would have the r in this
position and Vil says I don't care this
is a Tempo but it it's not a Tempo I
have to worry about right uh at
all I think most people would have gone
through the same transformation of
opinion about this line as I have and I
also at some point tried incorporating
the The Queen's Gambit accepted into my
repertoire in addition to the grinfield
and the dc5 lines to begin with look to
me like I shouldn't even study them how
can black lose this position like how do
you ever
lose a completely symmetrical end game
with no with no wees right and then I
got beaten by strong players like like
very very badly in particular in that uh
match against Y Bar in the 97 Uh Russian
Championship he just destroyed me from
from from a dc5 line and I thought yeah
okay now I understand it's not it's not
that easy you actually have to know what
you're doing but still every time I look
at this position a new I think balance
where's where's where's the problem
right exactly uh in this particular line
uh this particular position with the
King actually on E7 and the bishop on C5
there there is a potential issue like uh
just to put a a move on the board after
King E7 the potential issue as rare as
it might appear to be is that after
Knight D2 and again I'm just going to
put a a move on the board Knight D7 this
bishop on on uh C5 with the King on E7
I'm just going to go ahead for go
forward I see I see what you yeah and I
instead of going Bishop B4 Rook D1 I'm
going to go Bishop backwards to A7 and
then suddenly and shockingly there
actually is uh an issue with Bishop A3
so but I'm with you on this I mean I
watched the rematch in 1992 between
Fischer and spasky where Boris kept
going for the same Queen's Gambit
accepted position and hitting his head
and not really getting uh uh winning
positions or advantages and I just
thought you know at some point you just
have to say I got to give it a rest this
is actually very interesting because
that would be sort of the one way to
either justify playing Rook e one first
or Justify inviting white because it's
it's double- edged on the on the one
hand it supports the E4 E5 push because
often the pawn on E5 you gain some space
but it's also a bit of a Target exactly
and having it protected by The Rook Onan
is useful on the other hand I'm not sure
this is a good move but just to just to
put it on the board we now have a
problem with F2 hanging right the engine
says this still doesn't work because
Rook E2 is very strong and if Knight D4
takes takes here tactically this is
quite strong we are giving up on F2 but
if if you take with the bishop your
pieces will start uh dropping off uh so
Rook E4 successfully protects actually
everything you want to protect and this
position because of the King on E7 in in
large part with Bishop A3 coming up is
just very very bad for black right but
this is I think this is a very welcome
development because we might be getting
a a sharper Queen's Gambit accepted with
d takes C5 compared to some of the ones
we've seen over the years because black
seems like will have to accept the pawn
landing on E5 right and then some line
like this and H6 might not be a bad move
because you do want
to not to worry about the bishop G5
check IDE and Knight
E4 honestly something to play for this
very much looks like a a queenless
middle game this is I no longer feel
this is an end game right this is now a
queenless middle game with the King very
much in the center you might have to
give up the two Bishops because the
bishop on C5 doesn't really once again
to restate if it goes away and you allow
B3 you might be extremely unhappy right
so this could become quite sharp which
is a good news for us it is and I'm just
checking the database um there has been
one game play before it did end in a
draw and there black responded by
playing B5 which I believe has just
occurred and it makes perfect sense in
these Queen Gambit accepted positions
the move A7 A6 is very often a Prelude
to this Tempo gaining move B B7 B5 uh
Queens Gambit accepted was in my
repertoire defensive repertoire
throughout my professional career and I
really enjoyed the idea that my Bishop
on C8 which is very passive suddenly uh
flare a new on the long diagonal I go
Bishop B7 and suddenly I turned my
passive Bishop into a very uh aggressive
on especially against an early E3 E4
when I felt the pawn hadn't been protect
protected how did the game go J well
funnily enough I was just checking and
it literally went B5
draw let me guess it was wasn't played
in the grand chest or the was not it
absolutely wasn't
no what did I win with with we powerful
powerful guest who were the two players
it was predka and pron sorry I have to
forgive my pronunciation uh jump in
Peter B7 B5 where's the bishop going uh
the C4 Bishop it might not even once
again the Sam Shanklin principal what if
we do it anyway appears to be a possible
reply even even night G4 KN E4 somehow
works out becomes very very sharp uh
yeah currently it's suggesting that yeah
it be like we're not expecting this but
this is currently what my screen it
wasn't my first variation what my screen
is showing me Bishop D5 yeah my my my
initial reaction was that we just drop
it somewhere uh maybe F1 maybe B3 those
would be the two squares I would
consider but yeah you you have to uh at
least consider E4 E5 because if you give
black let's say we play Bishop B3 and
black plays Bishop B7 or includes H6
here I think the inclusion of B5 and
Bishop B3 is very much in Black's favor
because counterplay on the queen side
will just come a lot faster also we've
completely ruled out our own main idea
of B3 Bishop A3 check so no longer have
to worry about that B5 is I think would
be a very welcome move here
because once again Anisha is on 12917 on
our
screen no this being a Nish this is not
a bluff he knows exactly so I think B5
probably does get met
by and then we we actually do have a
proper proper Brawl on our hands uh
which I would very much like to see tell
us about the Donnie Brook that might
occur E5 let me take the bishop exactly
fonte Knight let me take the pawn with
the pawn absolutely you're going to play
Knight D5 check I was no you're not
you're not cooperating no I'm oh
sorry that's an eye opener right there I
I think you can see it's not great but
the the extent to which it's not great
actually shocked me Machin says lost
Machin says game over despite this still
being equ material position but you can
see how this King on d8 isn't great yeah
the Knight is coming to E5 the bishop
comes to G5 The Rook on E1 is a
superstar in this variation so after B5
E55 so therefore don't take the bishop
yeah you have to move the Knight it
seems like Knight G4 has to be played
because if your choice is between kn
Knight G4 and Knight G7 you probably
choose uh Knight G4 cuz these positions
start looking I'm not happy Rooks Rooks
coming in G1 Knight still jumping to E4
the King on f8 catching everything
catching everything off so you agree if
you commit to B5 you will probably have
to commit to Knight G4 and in this
position you uh you might start to think
but honestly if you don't play Bishop B4
you're probably still in trouble I'm
finding this position stunning because
out of nowhere we're having a huge
tactical yeah exactly okay so the the
line will continue Bishop before you
know two pieces you have to play Bishop
G5 Che putting more pieces on we're
about to continue now up for gra Bishop
D5 yeah now Bishop D5 yeah I mean that's
a stunner right there Bishop to D5 and I
before today's round I kind of made a
solemn vow to myself that I will use the
engine less but here I think we will
will not make any sense and one thing I
wanted to show show you because really
this is a very nice illustration of just
how bizarre this position is Bishop D5
is by far the best move but the second
best move and once again reminding of
yours we have three pieces hanging
material is equal right Machin says we
can move one of them and let and let you
two take two of the others what and then
it goes H3 and it says white is not Wars
your turn wow yeah your move that's
incredible yeah ridiculous we are
currently a full Rook down but he has
the Knight on G4 obviously will not
Escape because b six is impossible and
so you you get to some kind of a
position like this where the pooring the
poor King on E7 the ideas of like G5 and
Knight
D4 C4 Knight D4 if if you allow me
Knight D4 and Rook takes E6 or Knight D4
and Rook takes something like this you
probably do make a draw with white we're
not playing for a win though I'm pretty
sure this is not anisha's idea there is
compensation not it's not great but
could you look at the line with Bishop
D5 that's ridiculous we absolutely so
that is by far the best move Bishop to D
Bishop D5 black unsurprisingly black
takes yeah so just just briefly if you
take on D5 after Knight takes F6 the
King has no good squares and white ends
up even though once again this is a
position yeah but we will win this piece
back because if it goes to D6 we
continue chasing it eventually it have
it'll have to go to some really poor
squares so the engine suggests you you
you have to allow this and finally start
developing finally start developing some
of our quein side you and if you
don't let's let's have a look at the
greedy KN Bishop takes Knight Knight E5
but it gets it gets picks up picked up I
just want
to7 Knight takes G4 now we threatening
to take on and now 97 can be met by Rick
e E7 check this does very very risky
King is coming out right you probably
and uh aren't going to enjoy this very
much as black I don't think no no it's
important to show these lines because
it's I found a very cute mate but
unfortunately it's probably not mate
because the king can run towards the
towards the center of the board yeah cuz
this actually this actually is
mate and I was for for 3 seconds I was
very proud of myself but then I realized
not obliged not not obliged
uh but we're getting a little bit
carried away so is not best Bishop takes
E1 is stronger Rook E1 is playable but
black will just quietly play Rook A7 in
response and it's a mess so the best
move is Bishop takes A8 and here by far
the strongest move is to start actually
trading pieces using the fact that the
bishop on G5 is still hanging and we end
up in this end
game equal material white has the better
structure slightly better pieces I
assume because the bishop will return to
E4 M but but probably probably closer to
a draw than it is to a white Victory but
you pick white here every single time
absolutely and uh well just bearing in
mind that Maxi V gra is also thinking
for a long time and Anish quite frankly
hasn't thought for at all at all so I'm
just thinking you know what are the
chances that Maxim is actually going to
play B5 he might
choose more solid idea perhaps your age
six was a was a problem because of E5
and then Knight E4 Knight E4 and then
suddenly questions I think B5
Pro this is not unplayable it's it's
clearly quite Pleasant for for white but
uh playing since we've sort of
established that controlling this
diagonal is very important and Bishop A7
probably creates more problems than it
solves you play something like B6
intending to follow it up with Bishop B7
the KN will come out to C6 once again
reminding white that now that we've
solved the immediate tactical issues
this is a bit of a Target so there will
be some counterplay against it this is
not horrible
it's I don't know if it's in mim's
character to allow white somewhat free
reign in the center like this because
you will have to play passively for a
bit burying the white threats but if he
doesn't know B5 is a very very committal
decision yeah thank you for that Peter
that's a that if they go down any of
those uh roads that that that's going to
be great exciting right turn our
attention to the game of Wesley so and
uh Richard rapor uh the king's Indian
defense is one of those defenses that
waxes and waines in and out of fashion
at one time Gary Kasparov was the
standard Bearer for the king's Indian
defense but nobody really picked up the
gauntlet thereafter however uh Richie is
one of those new generation players that
literally includes everything in his
repertoire including the King Indian
defense as does ding Lin ding Lin now
that I think about it he really likes a
king's Indian uh let's see what we have
we have a sameish with F2 F3 by uh
Wesley Bishop E3 A7 A6 Queen D2 Bishop
D7 that's a little bit of a a wrinkle
for me I mean in the old days they would
be playing Rook B8 as the main go to
Bishop D7 Rook B1 and that's also a very
different approach uh than what uh the
traditional approaches were this is all
standard for today's players I suppose
I'm not sure because Bishop D7 I think
that was part of how I was treating this
position because I there was another
period where I was not entirely
satisfied with only having one opening
against one4 and I tried the the Kings
Indian but it wasn't agreeing with me I
I really loved analyzing the aish in
particular because we're talking about
the mid90s right where the engines were
incredibly
poor compared to today's standards so
you had to do a lot of thinking on your
own and you could also uh of make a
somewhat convincing argument to yourself
that this old you know chess informant
evaluation with compensation or unclear
play actually meant something because
these days like you actually analyze to
the end whereas in those years like you
could get some incredibly sharp position
by move 15 17 look at it say I have
peace play I'm a PA down but I have
peace play I will have fun here and just
stop right and and the
zish the main like the old main line of
the zish right arguably is a very very
good example of this particular approach
where I actually had analysis of this
position but in those years you could
sort of
just add Le from here yeah uh and and
this is the kind of opposition black
very much wants against the very very
classical F3 Bishop B3 is aish uh Rook
B1 and first of all Bishop D7 is a
slightly different different move to
Rook B8 I think in terms of Knight
C1 yeah I'm not sure why let's say
you're preferring Bishop D7 to Rook B8
specifically against Knight C1 because
you pretty much always semi semi obliged
to go for these lines and if you are to
play C7 C5 here you would much rather
have the Rook on d8 in in preparation
for the B file being open right rather
than the bishop on D7 which does nothing
but I suspect uh rard has some idea here
maybe something like Knight H5 F5 or or
in this position sometimes they say I'm
supposed to be worse in this structure
but I don't believe in it so I will just
play right uh so maybe he had something
like this in mind but TR ban in general
is something they were already doing in
in in the mid to late 90s idea being
Black's counter play is often connected
with the idea of playing B7 B5 so let's
put it on the board and the reply a very
decent reply very often is just taking
and playing uh B2 B4 stopping the the
advance and then continuing sort of uh
d594 becomes the idea uh you can play in
the center currently in this position uh
you can take on B5 and Rook takes A2 for
some reason isn't ah there there is a
reason yeah I was wondering white was so
heavy about you're trapping The Rook
nice taking uh taking on B5 GE slam shut
on that one and and also another way to
describe what Wesley is doing here is by
taking a look look at the next two moves
that happened in the game first of all
it's a it's a pass as long as Knight on
is on E2 E5 is more or less completely
unplayable because you just cannot play
9 D4 and if you have to drop it to E7
you're going to be in trouble right this
has been known since Fisher's times that
exactly the King goes Queen side now yes
the king never will be on G1 so all of
your C to play on the king side is you
can also actually start playing on the
king side yourself yes so not having
access to E5 you're looking elsewhere
for either passing moves our ideas so
rard actually played H7 H5 here which
looks a bit weird has doesn't it have
the idea that if the Knight comes to G3
I've seen them go H4 of course yeah of
course uh but mainly I think it's a
useful waiting move we we are waiting
for white to commit to something that
will provide us with a target for
counterplay and Wesley says I don't have
to wait for B5 I can play B before
proactively wow and and just continue
gaining space everywhere right and
eventually The Way Wesley is setting up
his pieces I feel like the Knight is
just not going to leave the E2 square at
all we're stuck so we are probably going
to finish our development on the king
Side by playing G3 playing Bishop G2 and
castling very and then and then we will
think about how to how to further expand
yeah because for black uh you are now
sort of stuck looking for for things to
do you can play H5 H4 but once again
with with nobody here like I can maybe
even consider playing G G4 in response
and saying like to open the H file for
do me a solid exactly exactly what are
you doing here so yeah black feels like
if B5 is unplayable and I think if we
were taking on the previous position
we're definitely going to be taking now
that the A2 Pawn isn't even hanging even
defended yeah we have the the protection
so B5 doesn't appear to be very good E5
as we've
established needs the KN only to to
depart so we are kind of restricted to
all these kind of shuffles and then G3
and then G3 we can even start with h I'm
not sure if we need to start with H4 I
quite like playing G3 first and once
again H4 I will spend a Tempo on G4 I
don't know if this is apparently now you
can uh sacrifice the pawn so you have to
be a bit careful expecting Rook E8 yeah
and it it's kind of one of those funny
moments where if after Rook E8 Peter uh
white white plays A4 it's like the Five
Pawns attack but A4 is actually a bad
move maybe because of A5 and5 and the
night it's like I've given I've given
Black's night a rooll there's a great
expression when you have a lot of space
you've got to use that Spider-Man with
expression which is like with great
power comes great responsibility with
great space comes great responsibility
so you've got to mind your squares and
um you know we we saw the computer had
an idea of uh perhaps sacrificing
something in the in the middle of the
board can we show how yeah because
otherwise it looks like black is just
going to get squashed mhm I think it
pretty much always needs to start with
Rook E8 because if we are to sacrifice
this Pawn with Knight D4 while the
Knight is still on it two you need to
have most of your pieces already on the
squares where they need to be for those
sacrifices to work and the line where it
definitely did work was after G3 and H4
I made an additional mistake of playing
G4 yeah and now after all of this
happens yeah black has this nasty
counter counter strike yeah because fg4
KN Tak C4 just loses on the spot
everything starts coll in the center
also importantly after Bishop takes F6
Queen takes F6 this Knight is hanging so
this is also bad meaning that white has
to play something like Bish B2 honestly
position remains unclear I think this is
playable for white I will just go like
King D1 King C2 at some point it feels a
lot more this is an improvement
uncontrollable here and this but after
G3 I I like the move G3 H4 and just kind
of chill here can't we do something okay
Bishop G2 May encourage H3 but how bad
is that Peter I mean the on H3 it's got
to be considered a liability right it's
both I think it's it's very much a you
sticking in our Crow a little bit here
but of course if we have time to you
know finish theel and start attacking it
we'll just pick it up it will not be
defended for very long but we've wasted
so much time now that some kind of
counterplay perhaps with B5 with the
intention of giving this up and then
going E5 and blowing everything up you
can imagine this now being dangerous
with the white pieces so dangerously
restricted
so so maybe white has to be precise here
and actually not go G3 maybe H4 is yeah
I think H4 is maybe stronger will at
least shut that door on that counter
playh yeah intriguing well we'll
definitely keep an eye on this one as uh
both players are playing I would say
very enterprising coming in uh to this
round and it we do have the G the
position with B4 I just needed to update
my board there uh the other games uh one
game we haven't looked at between ala
fja against Lena Dominguez let's see how
the players reached uh this position is
it one of the London it was a London
system I tell you I have been seeing
this more and more especially in the
title Tuesday bulletz events it seems
like the London variation uh the London
system with Bishop F4 against the
Queen's Pawn opening has just become
incredible popular and we see black
actually employing the very trendy KN H5
variation I I'm looking at this position
you just went Knight
G8 to F6 to H5 to F4 to
G6 haven't you just lost an an enormous
amount of time uh not particularly I
think I think this makes a decent amount
a decent amount of strategical sense
yeah if we go through this move by move
of course after Bishop F4 there is a lot
of potential plan here but this is as as
Yanka said this is very very fashionable
right you you wait for the Knight to
arrive on D2 then you take because these
types of exchange SL positions really
need this Knight to be on C3 for white
to be uh any better at all so white
obviously recaptures with the E Pawn and
if you look at this position now black
has this really poor Bishop on C8
compared to the bishop which will
eventually probably be on D3 and as we
will see in a moment it does land on D3
although via a two tempy uh route and if
you play Bishop D6 here white very very
happily trades and plays some kind of
position like this which you sometimes
get from londons you can also get them
from he takes D5 Caro there's a number
of openings which result in this
structure this is a very pleasant ede
for white and and the plan here which is
relevant will be we want to Castle and
then we want to plant this Knight on E5
supported with a four and you can
actually develop a very quick attack on
the king side if black uh sleeps on it
for like three months which is why
Knight H5 which is normally breaking a
lot of rules you you don't want to be
moving the same piece so many times in
the opening what it does is it very very
efficiently shifts this Bishop from this
diagonal so we're winning the uh H2 B8
diagonal for our own Bishop Bishop G5 is
a possible move here and black actually
repes with F6 this is how much we won
the bishop away from this diagonal
Bishop E3 was chosen by lza now this
belongs to Black okay Bishop D3 would
run into Knight F4 and both the bishop
and the pawn are hanging which is why
lza developed it to B5 first Knight of4
was played anyway castles castles oh
sorry not castles actually Knight G6
First bishop D3 and L has just castled
here so what black achieved by by this
very very long maneuver with the Knight
mhm is this diagonal now belongs to the
bishop on D6 and you also have this plan
of playing F6 and D5 which fights for
you know the freedom of the bishop on C8
and and also with that Knight on G6 you
control the E5 Square which is White's
main source of counterplay you know
White's gonna go Knight E5 F4 you know
just kingside attack here it's actually
not very clear what white is going to be
doing whereas black and you also
mentioned this F6 E5 plan I also wanted
to point out that the very oldfashioned
plan of just simply playing B7 B5 and
doing the old minority attack something
like Rook b54 is very playable as well
yeah uh for me um Peter it's not obvious
and I think our audience might have the
same question why do you voluntarily
Retreat the Knight to G6 I mean the
Knight was sitting there nicely on F4
and aren't you're supposed to wait for
white to give you the boot the old heo
well the thing is though is isn't white
actually in these type of positions
going to go G3
H4 and ask questions not really after
the then you got the temp so let's say
castle if you want to play G probably
connected with this I have a feeling
it's probably connected with this move
because white can use the fact that the
KN on for is hanging to to perhaps Force
black into into this structure yeah this
is quite unpleasant right you as a car
con player know this structure and it
can be quite okay for black but you need
to have pieces on much better squares
than they are here gotcha uh so I think
it's just a very tactical thing you you
would like maybe to wait for white to
push it with G3 because you're not doing
this for free but preventing preventing
preventing 95 was a more it was an issue
more immediate concern very very good
let's go back to our Marquee matchup for
just a moment
what guess what I mean knows knows
something knows but he didn't enter this
variation epared prepared but does mvl
know is the big question Anish knows for
sure Rook
E1 uh you know when you see a move like
Bishop D5 in modern chess today you look
at that and you go oh my goodness I've
just walked into my opponent preparation
and you get this feeling like if mvl
isn't prepared this is could to be like
over in dead I think the bailout is very
humanly
understandable take the r you take F2 as
you this is not as lethal as some of the
other uh things you could run into are
because actually the best line here is
the line that you are will be drawn to
precisely because you're playing against
somebody who is extremely well prepared
and you don't want to compete in
extremely long sharp variations where
you could go wrong so I
think the fact that this exists yeah the
fact that this exists is huge help of
huge help to to MV if psychologically
you're afraid to try that one I mean can
you get away with going Rook A7 is that
yeah you can play Rook A7 and it doesn't
lose the best move for white here is uh
Bishop D2 which is understandable
everything is still hanging so this
actually very cutely solves all of our
problems protects the
moves away moves away the Bishop from
the G5 square and after you take using
this we have also
protected how can you protect three
pieces with one move one move yeah it's
very very
impressive yeah it is honestly if you
whoops uh if you compare if you compare
uh where was
it this position this position with
Bishop takes E1 and Bishop takes F2
right
I think if you don't know and if you're
searching for something playable and
you're choosing between this and once
again let's not lose my place and this
you're pretty much always going to be
choosing Bishop B1 Bishop F2 this one
this one looks very dangerous the KN on
G4 is still very misplaced you still
have to deal with the uh problem of
having a very centralized King there on
E7 H3 is bothersome E6 is very
vulnerable just looking at this position
it it doesn't feel like it's lost but it
feels like it could be if you make an
additional couple of inaccurate moves
whereas whereas this one looks like it
should beh holdable much safer how do
these players match up JY well let's
have a look at the head to head and uh
take a look at this and Gary has the
advantage five wins over three
27 draws and remember this is just
classical chess I mean they played each
other in countless games rapid and Blitz
wow yeah Bishop D5 uh some great
preparation I'm looking at the clocks
I'm looking at
Maxine uh body posture I've got to
figure that Anish is the one who's
caught his opponent now the question is
can you get a serious Advantage the
position you have on the board really
reminds me of modern chess because it's
uh black has developed nothing but his
King
yeah that's
okay are going so I have I have a name
for that type of King what's that
Spartan king after the Warriors of
Sparta exactly out there lead from the
front right Leon usually usually a very
bad idea exactly Leonas uh leading his
army uh to Victory so that is the Anish
mvl game I want to turn our attention to
what I thought coming into today's uh
show was going to be the ma Mary matchup
game between Yan and uh Fabby and this
was this uh quiet trendy nimso in Indian
with Bishop D2 Queen C2 uh Fabby
immediately captured on C4 C5 you'd
almost think for a brief moment that
this might be a Queen's Gambit accepted
if we had seen A6 and B5 Knight B6
Bishop A2 Knight E5 an isolated Queen
pawn and this is a very good place to
stop in Prince principle Joy when you
see isolated Queen Pawn positions do you
favor the player with the isolated Queen
pawn and your Dynamic attacking ability
or do you like to play against the
isolated Queen
P thinking thinking I'm thinking it's
it's a difficult question actually
yeah yeah uh just uh taking a look at
our monitors there I see that the
Arbiters have the grand chestor
t-shirts that is uh at the Q Boutique I
don't know if Aris is actually aware
that he's become our fashion
model for the show but now he's trying
to get away from the
camera good AR never is never seen as he
uh proudly wears his T-shirt um yeah
back to the I question question iqp um I
find them very difficult to play against
especially
especially when there's a lot of minor
pieces on the board I feel like I have
to dedicate a lot of time to work out
the combinations and uh the potential
for white just to spring forward with
the pieces but then you know once I
figured out how to trade then I'm very
very happy so you know it's kind of a
extreme position that I have I love it
or I hate it okay sitting on the fence
you Peter isolated Queen pump position
you PR prefer to play against them or
with
them probably against I my repertoire
generally doesn't lend itself to playing
either but at some point once again in
my slav SL qga period I I started
getting some of them from the black side
in particular right and they're
surprisingly Dynamic and interesting to
play they look like they you know you
blockade on D5 you have a very nice
comfortable life not not how it goes
very often I got m in some very very you
know exciting games right for my
opponents at least maybe not not so much
for me uh the old Bic plan of f4 F5 in
particular if the bishop leaves the D7
Square just immediately trying to
undermine the pawn on E6 and introduce
the bishop on A2 back into the game is
still very valid right it feels like
precise play here should give black a
decent position but you do have to be uh
careful you do have to uh pay attention
to all of these details and uh the fact
that white very often is more or less
obliged to play against the black king
yes bod well for a very sharp very
interesting fight exactly this specific
position Peter first of all is it novel
are we in uh regular theoretical
channels the database is saying no but
the pece construction is very familiar
you know with a bishop on D7 Bishop E7
Bishop on A2 I I'm I'm immediately drawn
to Pet's idea of going F2 F4 I just
wanted to highlight another plan you
swing The Rook over to the the center
yeah you do a a rook lift yeah and get
attacking another idea is to go Bishop
B1 I've even seen I mean there's so many
ideas that I've had people do against me
like for instance I've misplaced my
knight and before I know it white knight
from C3 has transferred itself to G5
very dangerous do not allow that to
happen ever right yeah and on that
particular final topic that you have
brought up a way to perhaps fight
against it would be this move Knight A4
currently attacking the pawn on B2
attacking this Knight on C3 which does
seemingly force a pair of knights off
the board although you might have to uh
switch it from an isolani to the hanging
pawns on D4 and C3 different kind of a
relative but a different structure uh
which is maybe not something that
everybody loves doing because you have
removed the Target that you were
planning to play play against for the
rest of the game and you've given white
a slightly more mobile Center
but this is still perfectly uh perfectly
playable for black or you can play uh
Bishop six immediately I think just go
for normal ideas of is what I've done
and let's check out the head-to-head
matches and what do you guys predict I
would say even well yes sir well lucky
shot Grand but I'm shocked that it's
it's it's it's so few we just did that
mvl Anish Gary with don't care 27 draws
somehow I would have doubled the number
I would have said two wins two losses 24
draws or something you know because it
just I just have the feeling that these
two players know each other so very well
and from their candidates tournaments
with one another uh I would have
expected more games between them Queen
D3 on the board as for myself I just
wanted to say that I find I'm really
drawn to isolated Queen PP positions
I've played it I played them very often
on the white side and very often on the
on the black side and by the way Knight
A4 uh on the on the board if I had been
in in uh Fabby shoes myself in this
particular case I would have probably
been very quickly drawn to Bishop C6 and
Bishop D5 searching for
uh plays Bishop B3 which invites the
hanging ponds as no I wanted to say that
this actually gives me the idea that he
might know because that is prepped it
wouldn't have been so obvious to me that
this is the best move here I would have
looked at not at all because yes you
have to work out how to meet the threat
of Knight takes B2 specifically Knight
takes C3 is not a threat as such it's
just a move that you might have to allow
right but you have to figure out if B2
is actually hanging will then I be able
to come back and if if the answer to
those things is yes how do I react to it
but young could also have just worked it
out while fabbi was thinking both both
things are possible but uh with this
being quite clearly his choice he went
for one4 here he plays all three maybe
even all four first moves these days
after preparing for two World
Championship much as his his repertoire
basically includes
everything so it was his choice to play
one D4 it was his choice to allow the
Nimo which many people just don't do
these days because of how solid it is E3
Bishop D2 was his choice so it wouldn't
really shock me if uh let's say this
position was on his radar and it was
once again Queen C2 followed by what
he's done uh you could logically
actually arrive at this position in your
analysis but knowing knowing Yan he
might just be you in one of the moods
where he he feels what the right move is
and just makes it quickly because he
trusts his intin instincts okay continue
Knight takes E3 B takes E3 and you said
yeah uh you know the hanging ponds and a
close relative if you will of the I
queen Pond how does the engine assess
this how slightly better for white but
not very much although it does get very
sharp as I just noticed because the idea
of Bishop C6 is to play Bishop E4 Bishop
E4 but also to play Knight D7 because
the the best piece white has of course
is this Knight on E5 and if we deal if
we deal with that problem our life
instantly becomes much simpler and in
reply to that white goes Rook F1
stopping B4 as well very multi-purpose
move knight7 and it snaps snap snaps on
F7 we were having this discussion
yesterday the two minor pieces for the
rook in this case two pawns not a pawn
but two pawns that probably favors uh
the black king is unsafe as well so yeah
this this is very very sharp on the
other hand this bishop on D2 is not very
impressive we don't really have very
many attacking pieces so compared to
some other positions where this
sacrifice happens we're not really
trying to mate we're trying to actually
win the back win back the material
perhaps we're hinting at the fact that
H7 is also hanging very cute variation I
just thought of I don't know if it's
correct or not there is Rook takes C7
here here which I thought was quite
spectacular wow King takes we have
Bishop G5 okay but Queen takes and if
Queen takes still we have Queen F5 Queen
C The Rook falls off loose pieces drop
off yes and it's important to start with
Rook E7 because my first thought was
Queen F5 but then we have Bishop F6 and
this will no longer be available and
this is actually very good for black
with Queen D5 coming next move exactly
Rook takes E7 as a a cold shower yeah so
so for for this position if we assume
it's likely to
uh black needs to uh make sure they
don't get run over immediately but then
let's say I I saw on my screen that at
some point the engine was suggesting
just giving up on H7 giving up on H7
altogether to establish to I mean this
looks loses to Rook E7 but the idea is
to establish this kind of a kind of a
blockade the queen goes to D5 Knight
goes to C4 yes white has three pawns now
with the rot for the pieces but this is
this is going to be a very nice light
squared uh light Square block okay but I
I love this idea of night takes porn I
think it's so dangerous it's also very
typical of this particular structure so
the point I really want to make is uh
you get to this position your opponent
again is playing very quickly bar mind
he hasn't used that much time on the
clock I mean you treat the idea with
respect right you're not going to go
Knight to D7 because you're like okay
that's too dangerous how else can black
try to neutralize I mean can he just go
for
control over the light
squares not to play Knight D7 you yeah
Knight D7 it just feels too much I agree
with you I agree with you sort of in
general terms but I'm struggling to come
up with a good waiting mod I was
thinking b b okay A6 yeah that
was one of the options for sure but
potential b c C4 is playable also you
you might you might find and then you
set up the wall which I call G6 this is
a very important one and then maybe we
this even start pushing this is how you
geted this is what people do against
me and and and this is why I like I
spend a lot of time now you can finally
play Knight D7 but uh some kind of a
position like this might not actually be
H5 yeah because H5 Bishop G5 I think the
reason it starts with G3 is that it
doesn't really want
you to be able to start offloading some
pieces okay so it it goes G3 I can
imagine it even including King G2 Rook
H1 before playing H and yes you have
some squares on the queen side this
Knight might land on C4 or D5 but uh
very often you know white is in holding
pattern for now preparing to to improve
both on the queen side also I want to
mention this Rook on B1 will be quite
useful having played A6 we've somewhat
weakened Our Queen side so this Rook is
also going to be a bit
annoying and these types of structures
with the Bishops against bishop and N my
initial feeling would be is quite
Pleasant for to play for it's not
horrible for black but I'm always
choosing the white side of this position
a fascinating eyesight of Queen pound I
I have to include one of my favorite
stories if you don't mind put the Knight
back on B6 for just a moment and uh it
it comes from uh the book my my life and
games by Michael tall and essentially uh
if you don't mind put a Pawn on H6 for
black somehow put your knight on H5 for
white oh um okay uh Rook on E8 for black
okay and yeah we got a position like
this and Michael Tall he was thinking
should I sacrifice on G7 Knight takes G7
followed by Bishop takes H6 check
followed by Knight takes F7 mhm yeah and
that's a big fork or should I start with
Knight takes F7 King takes F7 Knight
takes G7 King takes G7 Bishop takes a so
he sacrificing three pieces well you
need some more pieces to be attacking
but or and and which piece should should
I sacrifice he had 50 minutes and
somewhere in the middle of his
calculations he remembered uh a poem
about a
swamp a hippopotamus that was stuck in a
swamp and he started thinking to himself
how do you get a 2,000 kilo animal out
of a swamp and he started imagining what
kind of engineering you might need to to
to lift the hippopotamus out of the
swamp he looked at his clock he had 3
minutes
left he scrambled and he grabbed the
first piece he did and sacrificed it and
he won brilliantly the next year the
next day and
prda Sport uh he read that a finely
calculated Sacrifice by Michael T
brought him victory in the Soviet
Championship yeah I know it's a Hipp
it's a nursery rhyme about the hippo
yeah I I know exactly what you're
talking about great fun great fun but
that came out of an isolate Queen Rook
A7 played by the way by mvl which is
honestly a bit surprising uh this was
the bishop D2 Problem Solver right to me
it's not that surprising because Anisha
has been playing so quickly and
psychologically you know I I just
remember Boris pask's words you know
when his opponent surprises him with a
very sharp he says well you know I'm
going to treat it with respect okay and
you know try to neutralize it as easily
as I can and then when I get home
there'll be some homework to be done
absolutely Rook A7 Peter take it away
well Bishop D2 we discussed Bishop D2 is
just very strong somewhat shockingly
white can also just play Bishop A4
continuing to leave a bunch of a bunch
of things hanging yeah and yeah some
some line continuing with Bishop B1
Bishop D Bishop B8 R uh D7 and um
something like this it continues yeah
this is still playable for white but I
think Bishop D is just straight up
stronger than so I'm I'm expecting
Bishop D and it's already on the board
yeah yeah why go for because this really
does solve uh White's problems very uh
well and it asks well for for for me the
the black king suddenly does feel uh
misplaced in the middle of the board and
I would say that Anish should be happy
with the resulting middle game position
so feels feels promising for white um
and it is I I it not it not only feels
promising it is Advantage OB quite quite
promising not winning but uh it's a very
good outcome for him Joy where would you
like to take us um can we head over to
the extremely sharp game between Wesley
so and Richard report this was our uh
King's Indian defense game we just saw
the move H5
B4 and Knight H7 seven that was not on
our radar I think we focused most of our
attention on rookie a prepping the move
E7 E5 Richard said okay um I'm not 100%
sure what I'm doing I'm not 100% sure
what you're doing but I am thinking of
playing F5 I am thinking of playing E5
how are you going to solve your problem
with the King Wesley said I'm going to
advance my Pawn Knight E5 Knight D4 and
we can see if white is just uh allowed
if you will Bishop E2 castles massive
massive space advantage in the center
Queens side so black has got to do
something here he cannot just uh sit
back and get himself pummeled because
Bishop B2 Castle C5 and the attack on
the king side's way too and yes I have a
question for you please do you like your
space I love my space I I've
always I've always
enjoyed specifically the sameish and
I've always had uh this kind of a love
affair with the Queens side uh
breakthroughs with C4 C5 and especially
when my opponent doesn't have E5 F4 and
G5 on the board in this particular case
uh I think it I think Richard needs to
do something rather dramatic and rather
quickly uh Peter I don't think he can
just sit back and wait these were
absolutely my my next words yeah the
moment you passed it on to me I was
going to say if BL doesn't do something
in the next three moves you're gone
you're going to be in so much trouble uh
and I like d594 I think it's nicely
timed because if you don't react to
Knight H7 at all black might be uh you
know emboldened to play F7 F5 so this is
this is just the time to do it because
now F5 feels like I'm not entirely sure
I guess with KN on D4 we we can just
continue developing we don't need to
punish it immediately we will we'll
develop our piece castle and then
eventually this will land on E6 with
great effect right uh S4 breaks
available to
Black apart from trying for some kind of
C5 I don't know what to even suggest
okay so let's try it C5 so C5 or C6 C5 I
I think C5 is just completely unplayable
because positions like this will just be
bad right and after B6 once again I will
play Bish B2 I will play castles
eventually will play H2 H3 to take away
the final Square from the Knight and
then I will play F3 F4 and you will
resign right that's the plan here that's
the plan so if you're touching the C
Pawn at all it is to play
C6 and you can I thought you can ignore
it but ignoring it does give black some
count to play because yeah suddenly
there is something to play for so I
think the reply will be just a take okay
and then choices are a bit unpleasant
because you can you can do this but then
after Bish P2
you're still not really threatening
anything you can play Rook C8 and maybe
white has to address the threat of C6 C5
uh I'm not altogether sure because even
this I I thought
originally I will find a tactical
solution to the problem of the the
hanging Pawn on on C4 but this
apparently is playable but after Rook C8
white can play knight3 Knight B3 white
can even play C4 C5 which often is quite
strong in the structures because uh the
night A6 is hanging but just basically
we're securing this very very
comfortable setup in the center we're
preventing the break and black is left
with pieces which are you know less than
impressive uh or on the same topic you
can start with Rook
C8 but then after Bishop B2 yeah C6 we
we get to very very similar positions if
you play C5 here uh bc5 Rook C5 is
probably better for white but some cter
play so with is still taking on
pan and yeah you can take with the
bishop here maybe and try to pretend
that the C4 Pawn is a target but all of
this is is not really making me
particularly excited for for Black's
prospects here it still feels like this
is absolutely the best the best shot you
have because E6 having played H5 is just
very very unattractive I feel like these
structures are U unattractive and also I
think think we can not we can just fail
to react mhm ed5 cd5 will not be a lot
of fun and can you try C6 now now yeah
but now I'm definitely not reacting I'm
very happy to yeah especially my knight
is on H7 and not on I'm not really
threatening to capture on D5 am I
there's no C5 no C5 and B5 and so
something needs to be done immediately
in this position and it feels to me that
it has to be connected with the cwn not
the ewn we don't like the F5 brakes H4
H3 really doesn't do anything at all
because we will just play Bishop B2
right we will play G3 we'll Castle it's
not really a source of counterplay B5 is
so well covered now that this break is
off the table so more or less by method
of an exclusion you you land at just
wondering you can go A5 first to try I
mean is this ever an idea need you go
you know I'm I'm in this particular
structure I'm not even against playing
B5 because I think if you completely
close the queen site I will actually
break through in a one day yeah so um
and this I think solves the the sheat
bone breaks I was kind of hoping C6
would be something I understand that the
computer also
have an additional an additional Trump
and if you like comparing it to the some
positions we've seen earlier you still
get your knight to C4 but in the process
you've given me you've given me such
a I'm not a Kings Indian player you know
one of the greatest Kings Indian games
I've ever seen in my life bar nun uh it
was the a game between Alexander boski
and Dr John nun and in that game uh Dr
John nun as black played F7
F5 uh Sasha captured on F5 Knight takes
F5 and is sacrificed in exchange could I
could I do something really uh obscene
Rook takes F5 and the idea was to go
queen queen f8 and sometimes there's a
tender point
it's one of the more famous Kings Indian
of all time I I will say I really don't
think white has done enough here to for
this to work but also I want to say if I
play Bishop P2 here in Castle and just
say I appreciate you being a hopeless
romantic I'm not going to indulge you
you know you're just not going to enjoy
this very much say you given the E4
Square for the night yeah details no me
with the details Jeffy
94 is actually a very nice Square indeed
okay very good very good well we've got
an exciting uh round uh it's not the
berlins today and we do have uh some
some uh fantastic positions to uh gnaw
upon definely let's take a look at our
standings before we go on our first
break and uh there we can see it well
there have been no decisive games so far
so that means that everyone is on tied
at the top Fabiana Carana Lea fuia Yana
pomi there many many players have one
and a half points and just to remind
everyone that Yan Kristof Duda has
withdrawn from the competition after
round two so his results have been
avoided very good and as we prepare for
our break well as you've been witnessing
our Arbiters have been modeling our
grand chestor t-shirt show off your
support for the 2020 3 Grand chest tour
with this amazing t-shirt the blend of
polyester and cotton will keep you
comfortable and the back features the
tournament locations for the 2023 Grand
chess tour events in Bucharest warar
zagre and St Louis and do all your chess
shopping uh needs at Q Boutique stl.com
and yes we do have the Black Friday
holiday sale we we usually offer 5% to F
friends and family 20% unhard of
discount
[Music]
get online absolutely it is the place to
shop and we are going to take our very
first break and in the meantime we do
have a video where Tony Rich is
discussing the history of the sville cup
so we'll see you in a few
[Music]
minutes it's a pleasure to sit first of
all with you Tony here because I know
that with seld cup is coming just nearby
and you are so busy with many things so
thank you for coming first of all and
now that we are celebrating the 10th
anniversary of singfield cup um I mean
it's important to kind of make sure
acknowledge the the role which you
played in this tournament and um let's
say your passion to Chas your
organizational skills made it clear that
this tournament has high standards so
how can you reflect on this journey with
singfield cup over those 10 years Wow
first of all uh I found out that it was
our 10year anniversary of the sing field
cup just a couple of days ago I can't
believe it's been that long honestly I
still remember that very first event
with just four players we had Magnus and
leavon aronian against gakamsky and
hikaro
Nakamura and and for for me watching all
of these great players come to St Louis
growing the event from four players that
year to six the following year into 10
players making the singfield up a part
of the grand chess tour um you know I
think I'm most proud of the fact that
this is Legacy building for the St Louis
chess club what the the singfield cup
has done for St Louis is establish it in
the Chess World um throughout history
absolutely but let's start from the very
beginning how how it was actually done
how the first one appeared and what was
the inspiration for the first singfield
cup the first singfield cup we owe a
debt of gratitude actually to seil we
are manry uh seil is a chess coach in
self also known as The Stepfather of
hikaro Nakamura um seil has been a great
partner with the St Louis chess club
over the years and he was traveling to a
chess tournament where both Magnus and
leavon would be playing um we reached
out to seil and said hey we would love
to get these guys to play in our our
first singfield cup uh at the time the
name wasn't even the singfield cup and
so uh seil while he was over there had
the opportunity to chat with both
players and secure their commitment to
play so that I would say is how the
first syn C came to be wow this really
interesting I mean I'm sure many people
don't even remember how all this
happened and how do you see the
tournament grown all these years from
that event the first one until the one
we have today T sinki cup looking
through all of the singfield cups it's
interesting from the perspective of the
broadcast the Arbiters commentators the
the crew that puts the event on social
media coverage everything has changed
about how we produce an event like the
singfield cup you know in those early
days it would just be a couple of
commentators in the basement of the
chess club a couple of camera operators
capturing all of the the footage from
both the playing Hall and in the studio
itself um you know and there were some
hiccups in those early days I remember
when the stream would go down and
everybody would be running around trying
to figure out how to make it come back
up uh I would say that that not just the
professionalism for the chess players
and in that side of the event uh have
improved over the 10 years but I would
say what the club has really done what
well has set the bar for chess
broadcasting and chess um coverage
exactly and also we know that single cup
is a part of the grest tour the big you
know the big tour and what role it plays
in the whole grandest tour and from
which moment actually it became the part
of it the grand chess tour started in
2015 actually it was a partnership
between the St Louis chess club uh the
London chess classic and uh our friends
at Norway chess as well um so there were
three classical events that first year
no rapid no Blitz um the singfield cup
is the one event that has been the main
State throughout the entire Grand chest
tour over its um Bo eight years I guess
now uh so the singfield cup to me
represents um kind of the bookend of the
grand chess tour season it's a classical
tournament that brings together all of
the very best players in the world um
and the players already know what their
standings are from the rest of the grand
chest tour they know what they're coming
into this and they know how hard they
have to fight and I think that produces
some very exciting chess in the
singfield cup absolutely uh as a
technical director of the tournament for
so many years which challenges you had
during all these years can you tell some
interesting stories and some challenges
which you had and you had to solve and
you solv successfully I could write a
book on the challenges that we have
faced uh organizing major events like
these things you wouldn't consider
geopolitics the closing of canals um
delayed flights and weather in Norway
can impact a chess tournament in St
Louis I remember spending uh very late
nights and very early mornings on the
phone with the US state department and
embassies and consulates around the
world trying to help players get their
visas in fact I remember one story
specifically I was with Yan npom Nishi
trying to obtain a visa to come to St
Louis the US Embassy was delaying and
and he didn't have time on his own so I
went with him in person to the US
Embassy in Croatia to try to obtain his
Visa unfortunately we weren't successful
that time but I learned about a lot
about the Visa process absolutely I can
imagine you know I've been through this
process also many times but thanks God I
mean players are here and singfield cup
number 10 is next to the corner yes on
the next corner so what are expecting
from this one this year's singfield cup
I think will be one of the most exciting
because it has some really interesting
players in it guys like Richard rapor um
Yan Duda these are some players that
have that are right on that threshold
you know we we see the magnet Carlson
the leavon aronian the Linea dominguez's
these are players that have been
established in the top 10 and have won
major events themselves outright many
times I think this is a really exciting
time for chess because we still have
those established players and at the
same time we have these upstarts that
are really coming into their own so I
think this year singfield cup promises
to be a blood bath across the board um
absolutely but what about the most
exciting singfield cup for you
personally which one was the most
memorable so there was a year that Vish
andan played the singfield cup uh and I
don't remember exactly which year it was
but driving into work that morning uh I
was driving just past the front of the
chess club and I saw vishy andan walking
into the Starbucks I have to admit I
almost crashed my car I was so excited
I'm like it's vishy it's vishy I had to
calm down and realize yep yep he's going
to play a chess tournament here pretty
soon um so that was really exciting this
is funny story probably the most
exciting singfield cup for me would have
been the one uh I think it was 2017
where Fabiano went 7 and0 in the first
seven rounds I mean watching that
performance and calculating the odds of
him doing it again and is he going to
make it in round five and is he going to
win in round six and Will he win in
round seven the excitement building was
was really memorable I wonder who were
all these people who were working behind
the scenes all those years can you name
maybe not all of them but those who
survived for for 10 years I think we
might have to roll the credits if I'm
going to name everybody because it's
going to be a long long list I say this
at the opening ceremony a lot to the
players they have a lot of contact with
myself or maybe with Rebecca who's our
event manager um Kelly tol who handles
travel and hotels for the players but
they don't have a lot of interaction
with with the rest of the staff
literally dozens of people who make
these events possible from the front
desk staff at the chess club who answer
the phone and sell tickets and make sure
that guests and members have access to
the commentary to the folks that
actually produce the events the Kevin
duin the Brian Adams Marcus baton that
are behind those cameras that are
configuring the devices and making them
happen Eric arson who makes sure that
the website and the technology is
working properly Leonard Odus who makes
sure the dgt technology works it
literally does take a village to produce
these event and we're really lucky to
have a great team exactly so my last
question like what do you think is the
impact of a sful cup for on the history
of Chess and the popularity of Chess I
think the impact the singfield cup has
on the history of Chess is um still
being made I think what we're doing in
St Louis is producing great quality
events we've done it for 15 years and I
look forward to doing it for the next 15
that's a great um that's a great comment
I mean Tony all the best of luck in this
and all the best for the singfield cup
which is coming tomorrow thank you very
much thank
[Music]
you hello I'm women's grandmas viim
tojan I will be creating content for
grandest store follow us on social media
and catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become become a
member and enjoy perks such as free
classes and lectures weekly tournaments
and so much more visit St Louis chess
club.org to claim your membership
[Music]
today we are back for round four of
sinkfield cop and so far the players
have kept us entertained with their
fighting today they came up and uh came
to the board full of mood for fighting
chass and let's remind ourselves of the
standings after round three and there
you can see well there hasn't been a
decisive game so far but uh it does mean
that the players are all there at the
top everyone is happy but everyone is
definitely looking for something to play
for and let's remind ourselves
especially for those players people
who've just joined the show of the
pairings Gary has the white pieces
against Maxim Vash MRA nomachi plays
against Fabiana Carana Wesley so and
Richard rort are currently engaged in a
very Dynamic battle and Ali Rosa fua
faces off against Lena Dominguez I have
to say Joy I'm looking at all four of
the games and I loving what I'm seeing
I'm seeing imbalances everywhere sharp
play good play uh Peter and if today's
rounds all end in the draw It's Des it
doesn't it has nothing to do with the
players cuz they're they're working hard
the fates are trolling Us by that point
that happens exactly and but yeah
starting with the game between yanish
and Fabiano corana are two World
Championship Challengers three
challenges between them exactly we had
this position on the board and whether
Yan still knows what he's doing or he's
working this out over the board b452 is
an inconclusive I think clock setting
here for for Yan but he is very much
showing the absolutely central line
against what I is doing uh after Bishop
B3 which is where we left off the
sequence of Knight takes C3 B takes C3
Bishop C6 very logical the bishop wasn't
really doing very much on D7 you would
perhaps like to have it on e4 plus the
Ed of Knight D7 so Rook F E1 very good
response and 97 more or less instantly
met by this sacrifice and Fab is now
thinking uh this is a very sharp
position we tried describing some of the
potential plans that black can have you
can play Queen e 8 you can play Queen f8
trying to uh make the threat of Bishop
takes F7 uh less problematic or there is
a very dramatic solution here of
actually allowing white to pick up a
third pawn and then playing something
like Bishop F6 and trying to establish a
life Square blockade with like Queen D5
Knight comes to C4 Rook perhaps in some
future could land up on h8 and you could
actually have counterplay against the
white king surprising as it may sound
but this is a very very committal
decision
uh with in Fab's case you can pretty
conclusively say he is seeing this
position for the first time right so I
I'm I'm expecting him to think for quite
a bit here because it's a very very
important decision that he has to settle
on thank you Peter and we have a very
special guest joining us by Skype uh we
do uh we are going to be joined by
awardwinning journalist Sharon Carpenter
and uh
Sharon Hi how are you doing lovely to
see you again Sharon you should be here
in St Louis I know I know I'm going to
be there in a few days actually right
now I'm in Sun La you can probably sort
of see the palm trees behind me um but
yeah we worked together a couple of
years ago yes it's so good to see you
again yeah it's wonderful and it's great
that you're going to come and join us
for the Gayla because that's our big uh
fundraiser if you will here in St Louis
and that's also going to be the site of
the closing ceremony the St Louis and
the grand chest store so we're looking
forward to seeing you yeah and Sharon we
are so excited to have you back for
strategy across the board so tell us
about your role this
year uh so it's similar to last year and
last year I had the opportunity to work
with Judith pogar who of course is
widely considered the best woman chess
player of all time didn't have to play
her at chess thankfully that would have
been over in in seconds uh but I got to
interview her live on stage and I'll be
doing the same thing with this year's
special celebrity guest who is Marina
toyen uh the sixth time em award-winning
costume designer who is behind the
costumes on the mask singer she has
worked with Katy Perry Justin bber uh
Taylor Swift if you've ever heard of her
of course we all have and you're
probably wondering uh what does that
have to do with chess well Marina
started playing when she was young she
was around 5 years old and in recent
years she's now using chess's
inspiration for some of her costumes so
if you remember Katy Perry's epic Super
Bowl halftime show where you had the
chess piece costumes the dancers were in
and the giant chess board well it was
Marina who was behind those costumes and
we're going to be talking to her about
how chess has inspired her creatively
but also as an entrepreneur in business
she's learned some business techniques
uh when it comes to chess so it's going
to be very insightful and very fun as
well I I can't wait sounds fantastic
it's going to be wonderful having you uh
for the Gayla and for the closing
ceremony when are you going to come back
and uh do some chess commentary last
time uh you were throwing some patties
towards the end
there I'm coming in today surprise I'm
right around the
corner hopefully I will be there very
soon uh with you guys on set that will
certainly be a lot of fun I think it was
2021 one that we we work together and
certainly learned so much working with
the best
Grandmasters um such as yourselfa so uh
hopefully I'll be back again soon maybe
next year what have you been up to what
are you doing in
La so I do a lot of Royals coverage
these days of course chess is the game
of kings and queens right and
historically monarchs have always loved
to play chess so over the past few years
in particular there's been a lot of
interest in what's going on with the
royal family after the queen sadly
passed away and then Harry's book spare
and then the coronation happening this
year um so I've been very very busy with
that working with CNN contributing on
CNN and ABC News and and E news as well
and then I I cover pop culture in
general but I also love to cover chess
when I can too so um it's certainly
keeping me busy out here in La it
sounded there very very busy indeed Shar
and we did see you on social media
playing a chess game so how's your
chess well if you read the caption on
that picture I lost to my uh
seven-year-old nephew which is sort of a
Bittersweet moment right because and I
have to say my sister was giving him
some help as well and she was using the
oldest trick in the book like the kids
have to go to bed hurry up and make your
move and you hurry up and then suddenly
your Queen's gone like that kind of
thing uh was going down but I love to
see my nephew really getting a good
grasp of how to play chess and he's
enjoying it especially when he gets to
beat Auntie Shaz you know that was a
victorious moment and now my my little
niece who's five she watched it happen
now she wants to learn to play as well
so that's great well lovely well you're
inspiring uh I can see uh your niece and
nephew there Sharon thank you and once
again uh having you at the Gaya will be
a lot of fun we'll look forward to uh
seeing you on set that's all happening
December 2nd JY it absolutely is
strategy across the board and it sounds
amazing for Marina and also Sharon to be
there and just to share with us their
chess experiences and their inspiration
absolutely Sharon thank you so much
thank you so much by see you soon all
right see you soon see you soon and
uh getting right back to the chess I saw
Knight F6 and C4 in the Fabby uh nepo
game and I really like the move C4 a lot
it just keeps all the tension in the
position again we've got two pawns for
the uh for the two pawns and a rook for
uh the two minor pieces and let's put
the Pawns in action Peter absolutely and
I think that the reason we haven't even
mentioned the move Knight F6 is very
specifically uh
the type of position that Yan is going
to get now because I think the Knight
normally very much belongs on F6 in very
many of this it covers the king side
many of the tactics that we were showing
in other variations would be completely
uh impossible with KN on F6 but allowing
C3 C4 so easily uh does give white a
very comfortable game going forward
because you're probably threatening to
play D4 D5 there's also very important
strategic idea of playing Bishop D2 B4
if we go back a move it's very very
clear what White's worst position worst
piece on the board here is it's this
bishop which is very restricted by its
own structure normally doesn't have very
much of a job on the king side if black
doesn't blunder something and now in
let's say we we actually Force white to
take which is arguably a very logical
thing to do you you you can't really
tolerate both of your Rooks here hanging
and by the way Knight F6 somewhat
amusingly is now offering white the
choice of Rooks the choice of Rooks to
recapture so you go Bishop G7 you say
say okay now do something make your uh
you have to take on F7 now we go Bishop
B4 and suddenly your worst piece yeah
you probably have to play Bishop f8
because improving white structure even
further doesn't really look very
attractive so you play bishop f8 and
white plays let's throw in H3 and then
eventually these Bishops will come off
let's make some moves here and uh let's
say we put the Rook on E5 put the other
one on E1 you have to of course make
make sure that black doesn't develop
some immediate counterplay against your
Center but in more general
terms uh with the queen on this king is
always going to be unsafe I think it's
incredibly important that we traded the
way one of the Defenders right black
having still having a dark Square Bishop
here would be very much uh in Black's
favor uh and also end games are not
entirely safe even no now that the the
Bishops have come off the board if you
imagine the same position with all the
heavy pieces traded off black probably
makes a draw but black struggles a
little bit so this is now seemingly a
bit of a free roll and we are speedily
heading towards that very same position
because everything up to King takes F7
has already been played and Bishop B4
looks incredibly logical now and we can
see fantastic uh explanation of the
position there Peter and I must say that
in those variations where you do get to
play Rook E5 and
doubling doubling the Rooks on the E
file
in particular The Rook are bossing the
minor pieces you don't have a beautiful
blockade on
D5 and a bishop on the long diagonal so
it just feels to me like Jan is going to
be very happy with the outcome of the
opening in this one another thing that
another position which underwent a very
very significant change and I'm pretty
sure Anisha is still or at least was
still in the book One move ago because
his very very last Choice here is uh
somewhat mystifying we left it uh
somewhere here in the game between Anish
gir and Maxim Vash gra Maxim made what
is the best move according to the
computer to which Anish very quickly
replied and with a very interesting
forcing sequence he played H3 it's
important to drive the Knight away from
the e file not even anything else but
specifically the E file and from H6
Knight being a knight cannot reach the E
file at all and now we go Bishop takes
A6 temporarily sacrificing a piece and
then attacking this bishop in such a way
that the only way to protect it is to
give up the exchange on C6 and if we
stop here and talk about the material
balance this is another one of those
that we've been discussing for the last
two days rook and pawn against uh two
light pieces uh two minor pieces but uh
here I think the evaluation very much
depends on the next few moves because
black will be completely fine if black
uh actually synchronizes like
coordinates his pieces properly but
currently it it looks like a very
disjointed Army which doesn't really
work together very well Rook A1 is a
very logical start because you you want
to open fight fight for the open file
Rook C8 very obvious response and now
Anish actually reasonably quickly made
the move F2 F4 which the engine does
make but it makes it a bit a bit slower
it starts normally by Rook C5 here
creating an annoying threat of Rook H5
and also I think importantly cutting
away the idea of Knight F5 because this
can this can just be taken with the PIN
along the eile so you provoke or maybe
even Force you can say Knight F7 and you
play F4 here ahuh and now the threat of
f4 F5 is extremely annoying for black
because uh it's just a full piece that
is being threatened and if you play
something like King D7 giving a bishop
on squares you can absolutely include
more pieces in the game and this is now
becoming very very difficult to
contain judging by what I see on my
screen it's probably still within the
drawing margins with absolute absolutely
perfect play but perfect play is not
very easy to to achieve especially when
your clock is uh there such a difference
in the clock but but after F4 very
specifically allowing Knight F5 uh is uh
in Black's favor although you have to
work out why G4 and F5 isn't winning I
guess it's not winning because
specifically Knight E5 exists there's a
knight e and there is a knight2 fork
there in the end if you take on E6 yeah
that hurts
that does how do these two players match
up well let's take a look and what are
your predictions yasa even no no no no
it was a 5 to3 in anisha's favor and
remember with 27 draws between the pair
and just classical chess alone and wow
what a game we've been treated to so far
okay so night F5 so the inclusion of the
move Rook C4 first Peter I think Rook C5
that F2 F4 was suboptimal then that's at
least the suggestion I'm seeing so far
and I didn't have very much time to
analyze this properly but the suggestion
seems to be that Rook C5 was more
precise and now black should be
surviving this but uh isn't isn't this
still like ideas of Rook C5 in the air
Rook C5 we can still go Knight D4
because the five the five knight5
Remains the Same I was thinking of
Swinging The Rook over to
H5
I'm going all in for that
porn I like the way you're thinking this
is this is actually pretty good and uh
the fact that black has to give it up is
is an indication of how decent this idea
is but now your Rook is a bit misplaced
the only real square is B7 and Blacken
for instance uh it's not the only move
but a good move here would be 9 d8 very
specifically because it allows us very
important Tempo to play let's say Rook
B6 Rook C2 and and start launching our
own counterplay and this as you can see
is suddenly very double-edged right
because as we were discussing during the
previous broadcast one one way to assess
these positions is one two three one two
three
four four quick M quick quick quick M Uh
current position uh Knight is on F5 I
can play it slowly uh Peter I'd love to
play G4 and F5 and d d da but slower
ones do you like yeah the Knight
F3 um my guess is we now have to unpin
ourselves finally because it's a little
bit too but Annoying Rook C5 Rook C5 I
like this idea of doubling on the SE
line I do too but hold on here we D4
let's let's go Knight B4 for in because
Knight D4 I didn't really want to
calculate some tactics so we can take a
G4 and drive the Night backwards for a
change yeah but it it still feels like
black is s of get getting better
coordinated this one will come to to D5
and suddenly if you imagine let's say
this position there are no more useful
entrance sares on the C file that's a
good point I was also thinking it's
business time with the Knight coming to
D3 yes uh could easily change absolutely
and that5 was just a demonstration 93 is
much much stronger in this that's for
yeah uh going back again to the current
position so Knight F5 Knight F3 if you
don't mind King F7 and just uh waiting
um what is Black's very next move
B D5 Bishop D5 maybe is my dream move in
this position H7 H5 is also useful just
making sure that G4 we can get some more
the again King F2 I I'm thinking can't I
launch my kingside Pawns in certain
moment G4 F5 even even in sort of I
understand trading the bishop for the
Knight is maybe not that attractive but
some position like this like I will I
will get the Rook over to D6 I'm
probably not winning this with black
because it's still a bit shaky I don't
have full cination and white probably
survives but how are you going to move
any of my pieces I can move your pieces
right I can I not go Rook C5 and say
Rook
D6 and then he's just keeping Knight on
C6 this is very very sturdy I I feel
like this is a position of very you
can't make any progress right so yeah
yeah there is like the doubling of the
sea line and then you start advancing
your well well I can imagine want to
play Rook E4 and King E3 and G4 yeah
might I I like Yanka suggestion better
to keep everything in place here just
going Rook C1 and asking asking to uh to
make a move but even maybe moving it
moving it back to E7 or Rook E6 might be
a move right cuz you don't really want
to allow rookie one rookie two and if
you put it back I'll put it back as
well yeah so I I think we'll we'll let
Anish think and honestly the pause there
I also saw he was briefly on our screen
after night5 landed right and he sat
down and and went into the full you know
hand hand in hand in in head in hands
mode it seems to me that maybe he uh
mixed up something he knew that this
sacrifice is best line he knew that he
has to go for this position with Rook
against pieces and he remembered there
is a strong F4
somewhere and and just what what order
is he supposed to play them yeah and
another thing that I think is very
familiar to to to most of us is that
feeling where uh you have this mental
picture of how the position you're
aiming for looks but you don't exactly
remember the move order MH and in a way
very often it's better not to know
anything like I think Anish would have
done better if he was just given this
position after Rook C1 Rook C8 and told
to think mhm uh compared to the
situation where you have this vague
picture but no direct lines present
themselves to your mind and you sat
there torn between trying to think and
trying to remember right and you often
end up in this kind of no man's land and
make moves like a four which are like an
echo of something you you knew you're
supposed to do but it was the inclusion
of Rook C5 that that makes all the diff
and now it's might it might be slipping
away if I could go back to a mo for a
moment apologies uh Peter where Bishop
takes E6 was a anisha's move and the
move I wouldn't necessarily be looking
to give up the two light Square pieces
two light pieces uh Knight
D4 KN D4 they just play6 C5 and the
thing is you have so many pieces on the
dile that now Rook d8 is a massive
massive threat so you will now spend two
temp bringing them back like Bishop yeah
you you play something like this then
you play something like this in the
meantime black you know gets Bishop B7
gets the Knight to F5 gets the Knight to
either D7 or C6 Prov and this already
this already looks lot more alive right
so that was why he felt it necessary to
take on E6 immediately I think4 is
counterproductive something like Bishop
B3 is very playable but even here after
Rook
d8 you can sort of name a number of
moves black will quite happily make
right Knight f54 Knight F7 I assume
Knight C6 with the idea of Knight A5 is
something to aim for E6 C5 is very often
on the agenda as well to maybe play
Bishop B6 whereas for white you know it
looks very attractive aesthetically but
how we making progress
mhm and also a for from that matter
Bishop B3 Rook d8 Rook E2 so I making
progress by doubling up yeah and I'm
forcing E5 and I'm proud of my myself
having forced you to play E5 but you're
not upset I'm not that upset here
because I think Knight F5 Bishop B6 is
coming in quite quickly if we could
already play4 here we'd probably be
winning right but it takes a long time
to organize got it and yeah and we also
have to return to the I think I think a
pretty obvious fact that here he was
still very much in book yes and the
engine I think is quite conclusive on
the topic of whether you should be
taking on six here or not okay right
very good thank you Peter does look
like but no cigar for Anish um let's go
to the sharpest game of the round so far
would that be Yan against Fabiana Carana
very good another piece in Balance there
on the table and well we did see Bishop
B4 right Bishop f8 on the board and then
now d d D5 and uh Fabby has no
intentions whatsoever of helping uh the
structure Bishop takes B4 a takes B4
that would just be very useful for why
isn't annoying when your opponent is
cooperate and we're probably expecting
Rook on A1 to see1 again this is one of
those imbalances we we do have two pawns
and a rook for the two light Square
pieces uh open open E file I feel like I
would rather play the white side here
I'd rather take the material uh the two
pawns and The Rook meaning seven versus
the two minor pieces well it's
definitely a lot more comfortable to
play with the rook and the horns because
of the open E file and the slightly
dodgy King yeah for me it's the dodgy
King actually the King on because it's
something that black will always have to
have one eye on exactly and so I would
play Rook A1 C1 and the time factor is
huge actually it's almost well it is
it's more than a two to one uh in favor
Fabby well he's not the greatest in time
trouble but he doesn't get himself in
time trouble this soften Peter this is a
very big Edge normally fabbi extremely
well prepared he knows his middle games
openings inside and out he doesn't find
himself nearly an hour down on on the
clock not very often but I will I will
say that it felt to me that the very
committal idea of playing D5 pretty much
instantly instead of I was including H3
here for instance uh I think maybe it
made fabi's life a bit easier because he
can now look to perhaps establish some
kind of a blockade for instance after
after Rook A1 uh there is a slightly
weird but seemingly working idea of
playing Bishop D6 very much provoking C5
but H2 is hanging and it's not enely
pointless to win that pawn like C5 I
will take on H2 and then I have a very
comfortable Square on F4 for both the
bishop and maybe the queen is even
stronger trying to swing it over to H6
uh so you can't really give it up you
have to play H3 and now we establish
this kind of a blockading situation
where C4 C5 is going to be very
difficult to organize and will also even
if you do organize it will just lead to
simplifications instead of and Advance
yeah exactly and and and with this shape
you suddenly start asking exactly
where's your where's your progress
coming from we've we've robbed ourselves
of the E5 Square for The Rook mhm uh you
can drop the bishop back to C3 hoping to
create some threats on the king side but
you have to do it in in a way that
doesn't blunder the C4 Pawn so this will
require some organizing like you can
start with Queen F3 but after King G8
once again Bishop C3
is well still you can take even even the
simple Rook of eight here seems what's
wrong with taking the pawn you've got a
back rank I got a back ranker
yeah it's still playable
like you can do that but I I'll show
I'll show you tactic because it's very
relevant here this does lose this does
lose on the spot yeah the bishop is
stronger not running anywhere cheaper
please yeah Bishop B2 is stronger
forcing the queen to retreat and then
you take on F6 but the engine do holds
even that but even if we just decline to
calculate any variations and just go
Rook F eight this
suddenly looks like a much improved
situation
ISF yeah the king is safer white
actually killed off much of his own his
own play yeah I think D5 I think D5 was
a bit Hasty I think Yan he knew he has a
very good position and he was also uh
echoing what you were saying about the
fabi's time management uh fabibi doesn't
generally get himself very low on time
so I think the temptation to continue
playing quickly to continue putting
pressure on the clock uh is very real
but maybe it was better in this
particular case to actually invest some
time into try and to figure out how to
proceed uh
efficiently um just on that Mo note once
again you had recommended H2 H3 specific
I like can I ask what's going to happen
if I encourage you to push that pawn one
square further so after Bishop D6 so
Rook C1 Rooks yeah and now you and now I
wanted to go this was the pawn sacrifice
no not H3 H H4 H4 sorry H4 I want to I
want to yeah let me let me do the same
and ask you what what the big idea is
now now I I just really wanted to go
like H5 H6 and try to
weaken the yeah it seems to I know H6
yeah it's Alpha zero exactly I mean it's
modern HS right and you have to consider
I actually quite like it there are some
tactical issues with it but I want to
disregard the Tactical issues and and
try to see how I would react if I didn't
have have the Magic The Magic In Front
of Me yeah I have a feeling that he
would actually unnerve me a little bit
Yeah because my my my initial reaction
was I can do this and then ask exactly
who is going to be mating who on the
king side but engine disagrees with it
says that some position like this is
definitely an improvement for white
because this king is not very safe and
there will never be any real play
against the white king I wasn't sure
about that but seems like uh that's not
a very good reaction you never play G6
you pretty much never play GH it just
looks I mean machine says you can but in
a practical game I would be very very Lo
to to play GH uh and having established
all that engine says Knight G4 is very
strong introducing the idea of Bishop
takes B before and then Queen H to check
so it just drops off right so there is a
very specific reason why it doesn't work
but if if I hadn't known that I think I
would be uh treating this with with
great respect and feeling that this is a
a logical
continuation we'll see we'll see what
Young does Peter if you played after H6
G takes H6 you gotten a platinum
membership in the pond grub Association
and also also that is really that's very
very cheeky Rook C1 I wanted to go uh to
the game of um uh Richie uh Rapport
because I was very curious how we've
seen this position in analysis well Rook
ac8 I'm not 100% sure I thought we were
no no we we were also doing that C6 was
our major stuff we had this exact line
on the board and we kind of cut it here
Bishop E2 C5 C5 we we we discussed bc5
Rook C5 being not very clear clear and
therefore we still take Onan and yeah
rard chose to take with the
bishop and this is uh much better than I
expected I thought white should still
have a reasonably comfortable edge here
because
you know those two those two attempts at
counterplay you know you it seems like
you play two different games here with
black right you played this kind of a
zishi play game on on the king side
where you played H5 for no particular
reason Knight H7 for no particular
reason right and then you switch to
playing in the center with Rook C8 on C5
Rook c yeah but but it seems like
counterplay against the pawn on C4 uh
does uh generate enough for black here
not to be too worried I suspect once
again the B2 B 3 would be a very strong
move here exactly followed by Night D5
but not allowed sadly sadly for Wesley
not allowed currently the engine
favors kind of cutting cutting the two
Bishops cutting the knot and just saying
you know I'm going to solve the issue
the one issue I have here is the Pawn on
C4 let's just put it on C5 and play from
there by the way I love that as a
solution inviting black to open up the
Rook on B1 I mean if you'd like to take
my Pawn on C5 and help me develop my
Rook on one I'll be I'll be delighted I
think it's quite clearly at least a
little bit better for white but the
question is how much and the question is
how you how you respond to this with
black black I mean the engine starts by
playing E7 E6 my big question is what
happens if we Castle uh it tries
tactically by taking take taking on C5 I
thought maybe it was intending to use
the fact that the Knight on C3 is
hanging but no it just drops The Rook
back to C7 drops back the very
importantly we will now be fighting for
the D4 square and yes the pawn on B7 is
still weak but there's enough
counterplay for us in the center for
black that that we aren't as worried as
I would have suspected castles is not
the the best move it's suggested that
Knight knowing that D take C5 is coming
we can start preparing for it instantly
by playing Knight C5 and then
recapturing with the Knight it's a bit
better for white but it's actually
completely
playable and uh other moves black
obviously wants just to drop the bishop
back to D7 and start threatening the
pawn on C4 so if you Castle either
Bishop D7 or actually Bishop E8 is much
stronger than mishop D7 uh to preserve
some counter play along the defile I
suspect and you can't go Full Throttle
right you can you should probably but
this seems to be uh the idea here is to
play Knight
C6 and this is where putting pressure
having the bishop on D7 putting pressure
on on the on the D file is coming into
play but yeah all of this is very
concrete because once again if if in
this position you make some kind of an
indifferent move I don't know which one
to make let's say Knight F6 and we go
Rook fc1 this is a dream this is
horrible for black a dream position I
mean white doesn't have to Castle right
you can put the Rook on
C1 that is true and then uh meet Bishop
D7 with a night move probably back
because you can't go forward comfortably
it will get chased away kicks out yeah
you have to go back I don't hate it at
all because once again given enough time
we will Castle we will put this guy on
F2 probably we'll play Rook fg1 F4 F5 is
something to always consider we have our
space we have our space so something
like this and we just play a game but
once again perhaps black and judging by
what I see on my screen it's a matter of
one temper if we give white the move
here white plays something like Bishop
G5 or Rook F G1 white is doing really
well but right this moment you just have
the time this seems to be this seems to
be in time and this seems to seems to
equalize probably hinges on uh the fact
that after C5 here black has G to play
with like Rook E8 Knight C4 the other
Knight coming to G5 if the trade happens
these are very very sharp very Dynamic
positions which could be much better for
white because but pretty much every
single end game will be better for white
because of the majority on the queen
side but while the Queens are on the
board and a lot of pieces are in on the
board there's a lot of Tactical
skirmishes available in the center my
own experience in the moroi I would get
this position as white and I again I
would just I would assume uh joy that I
am so much better I've won the two
Bishops great I agree I would love to
play the move uh B4 B3 but I would think
okay look after C4 C5 I my my my C5 Pawn
is is stable and safe uh the night on H7
kind of looks a little ridiculous to to
my eyes uh I've got the D5 Square
again reiterating my point two Bishops
and and maybe the fact that I have a
Pawn on C5 I could even utilize the B6
Square something like Knight D so I mean
it it's one of those things where
visually I would feel I'm doing really
really great I'm really kind of stunned
that I don't have a big Advantage
according to the engines it's is strange
right yeah but I think on a practical
level I think we do have something we a
lot but but I wouldn't have said I have
a little smidge here or there I would
have said boy you know like I'm just
piling up all the advantages let me
count them uh a bit of a stunner uh for
me that Wesley doesn't stand uh a whole
lot better uh let's uh drop in on the
game between Ali Raza and lanir uh this
was the the night tour if you will the
night went from E7 G6 oh hold on how did
the Knight somehow the6 H5 F4 G6 yeah it
took it six moves to get to the G6
square and when we left it we had just
seen the move Bishop to D3 castles
Knight
G5 Al that going to need some
explanation uh to tempy to provoke the
move fh7 H6 Peter was it worth it I'm
not sure because to be entirely honest
I'm not even sure we want to take on G6
here all that much because let me make a
move yeah you take on G6 I take on G6
yeah you you go Rook E1 and go G5
honestly I start liking this for black I
think I think I take black I I take
black every every day of the week here
so I I I I was a bit shocked by this as
well because uh there there's there's no
call for that you can do you can do the
things you will be doing anyway right
and uh and play but yeah lza invested
two full Tempe wow into this and
provoked Knight C7 which is also a
perfectly reasonable move uh Rook E1 I
was even wondering if it make sense to
play Knight F5 here apologies could he
have been intending to play after Queen
H5 here with the idea H takes Knight F3
could this have been his intention and
then he shied away from it at the last
moment I would need to look at the
timings because yes honestly this is
easier easier for me to understand than
just playing G5 KN F3 but it doesn't
seem to work because of very
specifically Bishop B7 and if you have
to trade away your knight like what are
you going to give mate with yeah I need
a work on H3 already don't I you problem
you problem hear that after Knight C7
I'm probably already prepared to play F7
F6 next move and yes you can win one
more Pawn for the piece but he will lose
long term uh but yeah this is a very
strange sequence which we missed sort of
watching live because other boards were
seemingly more exciting and yeah I would
like to know what happened there Knight
C7 Rook E1 as I said Knight A5 is
playable
but upon considering it for a bit longer
I thought why am I so eager to trade
away this bishop on E3 which has no
moves right I think the reason ler isn't
playing it is not because he didn't like
this structure I think he would very
much this structure with a four five or
four coming in it's just that white can
play something like Knight F1 and say
please take on E3 it really isn't doing
anything please spend two moves just
trading my worst piece right so lineer
for now played Bishop D7 right uh White
played Knight F1 already here I was
wondering about F7 F6 but after F7 F6
you can play H4 I was also wondering if
maybe a kind of a typical reply would be
you wait for F6 to land and only then
you play C3 C4 right so I thought okay
Rook C8 takes that away L Resa play day
four which is I was about to say Joy I
liked your minority attack I'm old
school I've always like B7 B5 but A2 A4
stops it stops it for now and ler is
thinking and uh there is a number of
shuffling moves available to black but
in terms of active ideas I think it's
between F6 and shockingly sometimes A5
even yeah uh with uh although ideas
after A5 they're kind of very long term
because what I would like to do is this
Abra Kadabra but it takes it takes three
it takes three moves and we also have to
start with King h8 so yeah but you know
you have the time to actually wait with
F7 F5 and position so yeah you can do a
lot of uh maneuvering absolutely going
to interrupt you Peter and say we've got
a a a tweet yes and uh we're going to
reach out to social media invite tweets
but apparently this tweet in particular
really got as uh uh um curious we love
it when everyone at home joins in the
conversation and joins in the fun
because we are having a lot of fun
watching the chess in the studio so
there you can use the hashtag us chess
Champs and uh here is the Tweet oh I'm
Kevin winter
asks oh Kevin Yi and yasa sell me the
caracon I have heard that is all porns
and no hope that is
terrible that will go on the back cover
that will go on the back cover and we
will use it as a as a as a promotion for
our uh new book winning and hoping the
car no it's true uh for those of you who
would like to play for wi is black do
subscribe to the new book uh by joy and
I winning with the caroon yeah 50/50
right it's a partnership down the middle
all secrets will be revealed in that b
exactly uh not available anywhere I know
but A2 A4 Joy you what do you think
about these uh block positions these
Carl's Bad structures do you like Ali
raises position or you like linear for
you what do you find more uh you know I
I actually find it quite rewarding to
play on the black side of these things I
know black doesn't have that much space
and the bishop on D7 has some kind of
connection issues but you know just just
forget about that piece it will play its
part later on in the game and there are
some things that really appeal to me and
first up is that white doesn't have a
plan apart you know yes white can go A4
maybe go A5 but that's going to get
jammed up and Black's plan is actually
more to do with just waiting the time
and also improving the night on E7 I
think that that should be on D6 on D6 in
fact yeah wants to be it wants to be on
that square well that's going to require
a lot of shuffling it means that that
the bishop is going to have to go you
have the time all the time in the world
I also really like the aggressive plan
of going F6 E5 I think that one will
send a lot of chills down res a spine uh
for me I I kind of like white a bit I I
I think I have two bad pieces the bishop
on E3 is making a woeful impression the
Knight on F1 equally so I would kind of
like to put the Knight out here on G3
and H5 and very much to Peter's point I
do want to meet the move F7 F6 with the
counter C3 C4 so in my mind's eye
putting the queen on B3 in preparation
for the move C4 getting in the
A5 um well we'll see uh as I think that
this is a rich position I wanted to go
back to no nothing has been nothing
happened between
Richie everyone is thinking including
Yan he did play Rook C1 and I like that
line you were showing Peter with Bishop
D6 and I would like to explore it a
little bit more for him for a moment if
you don't mind Bishop D6
C5 Bishop takes H2 check is what Peter
put on the board King to H1 and queen F4
Joy now you take a look at the position
and you see this for laen Bishop on H2
this black king in the middle of the
Well Middle on the board is a little bit
strong but don't you feel like there
should be something here some action
going on right here right now or you
you're spidey sense isn't tingling no
there's no plent but it's on the in fact
I'm really worried about the King on H1
because you can just see the next move
is going to be Queen H4 and and or queen
H6 yes one of those two so I'm thinking
there's you know I've got this bishop on
B4 I've Got The Rook on E1 I'd love to
play Rook E7 check so I'm thinking that
I've got a preface whatever I'm going to
do uh with the move C7 best move in the
position the only move that doesn't lose
immediately but after Queen H6 you're
still in trouble I'm still in trouble
because you can't take them yeah because
after she takes seven black starts by
playing Rook takes C1 I can promote to a
KN with
Che this will break this will break the
board don't promote the pawn to a knight
so imagine this is a knight right the
black drops the king to G8 and then you
like lik for white this is not hanging
so you still have time to play Queen H3
but then after everything comes off
black is just better in this end game
yeah so no this this just doesn't work
oh uh for for me the interesting
question I think and Fa actually made
the second move that the engine quite
liked starting with Queen F4 starting
also a very logical move because I think
what you didn't want to allow is an
unchallenged move D5 D6 which would have
loged down a number of our pieces would
have disconnected Our Queen side from
our King side would have completely
killed off the bishop on f8 in
particular if white can follow it up
let's just make some stupid moves yeah I
don't know something like this okay C5
was probably not the not the brightest
but my point was we get the Ure and then
maybe we get to play Bishop C3 and trade
away the Knight on F6 and then the King
on F7 will be basically bereft of
Defenders and the bishop on f8 looks and
the bishop on f8 is really really poor
uh right in in practice here after Queen
D5 black will still probably be able to
reorganized and is not doing that badly
but this is something that you
absolutely have to worry about and what
queen F4 does is it
preventively sidesteps yeah puts the
queen on the good square and says now
you know Knight G4 is also something you
need to you need to pay attention to it
doesn't win anything you have Queen G3
in response but I think by this point
black isn't really worried about the end
games anymore because you have the
blockading C5 square right so once again
let's make you know a move of some
description yeah and talk about this end
game uh Knight goes back eventually
either you will take on f8 or I will
just play Bishop C5 myself I will
reinforce it with B7 B6 and then plans
like 98 9 D6 will come the opponent C6
is a Target there's majority has been
diminished by having to double our pawns
on the king side this is just Pleasant
for black the PA C4 and D5 yeah exactly
they're quite vulnerable as well if you
put your Rook on the wrong Square there
could be tactical possibilities there as
well and by the way uh okay uh we do
like to have a move C4 C5 no he took he
took on f8 first and then played C5
which is a very logical response because
you you do want to if Faby is allowing
this I think we've spent the last 5
minutes describing how important this
Square was break the so just to make
sure this blockade doesn't actually land
this makes perfect sense uh the
principal response here is still Knight
G4 can't do that Queen takes
H7 takes F yeah okay I I wish I hadn't
read
that influenced by the I wish I hadn't
read it because you're absolutely right
in Practical terms you can't do that
because queen of to King H1 you've
opened the f file for white yeah and
about to get even this is sort of
playable but but the really really
beautiful move the computer makes here
is Rook takes C5 ah which is basically
an immediate draw because you you you
have to give this Perpetual Your
Position will actively deteriorate if
you don't give this Perpetual because F2
is hanging C1 is hanging and you
obviously cannot take the Rook because
this is now uh just completely ending
the game on the spot uh so n G4 is
principled I think this variations are
findable in Practical play frankly Rook
C5 is not a move that will not occur to
you sure so that probably Pro like if
white wants to continue the game you
will have to play Queen G3 you'll have
to take with the pawn the knif will drop
back and Rook E5 yeah and this is an
interesting one that I think is valuable
to try and explain to our viewers why
aren't we pushing our passer one square
forward because giving black this very
very solid setup with the Knight coming
to D7 and then perhaps the pawn on C5
coming under pressure is why is still
fine but I think both of us yaser and I
I don't know Yanka are you agreeing with
us or not but I think uh in this
position Rook E5 just looks kind of
better because you want to preserve you
want to keep theity the option of
playing C5 and then your Rook might
slide across to A5 if if if if things
get uh traded where in break uh
territory here uh Jo uh tell us about
the standings you asking me to just
going to say take a look at the
standings absolutely let's remind
ourselves of the standings after round
three and you can see there's no
decisive games which means that
everybody has the same score and just
again to remind our viewers that y
Kristof Duda did withdraw after the
second round so his game against Anish
giri has been
voided and then of course during these
holiday seasons uh we have the jingle
bar party Central in the Central West
End uh at the World Chess Hall of Fame
go to the website and check out how you
might enjoy the festivities I know we
have an upcoming club uh employee party
uh to celebrate the holidays and the
jingle bars we're doing it take a look
hot chocolate biscuit hot chocolate how
can you go wrong exactly you cannot go
wrong so go and visit the jingle bar
we're going to take a break we'll see
you on the other side absolutely so
don't go anywhere
[Music]
uh so today's Community Day all the
parants of the US Championship are going
to schools around St Louis and you know
teaching kids um openings and games uh
tactics doing some fun stuff like hand
and brain some simos and uh we just
finished our first class and it was
really fun I see kids taking the um
skills that they're learning in chess
whether that be critical thinking
decision- making skills planning skills
and I see them applying that throughout
the rest of their school day whether
it's in classes or sports or even just
how they interact with one another and
with their teachers I play with my
auntie my sisters sometimes on a
weekends like we go to the park and we
play they be begging me to teach them I
like show them like new stuff like new
openings I show them that and so I'm
trying to see them get better and try to
beat me what I like about Chess is just
trying to have fun and learn new things
and maybe I'll get more into it and
it'll maybe be my full career I heard
that if you play chess you make bad
decisions in life so I always want to
make the bad decisions in life I can
tell you that they've engaged more in uh
critical thinking they are looking
analytically and moves and trying to
think ahead I like the um complexity of
Chess how you have to think about every
single move you make like every move you
make whether it's going to put your king
in check whether is going to put put
your anything in danger whether it's
just a move that you make everything
counts in the long run I like um how it
makes me use my critical thinking makes
me look at the whole board I think think
it's teaching them to be persistent you
know we have a lot of students who it
takes them like it may take a few weeks
or even months in chess club to master a
particular strategy or skill um and what
I think that teaches kids is even if
they don't get it the first time around
or even if it's difficult the first time
around um it's worth sticking to it well
one thing's for certain without the St
Lou chess club we would not have chess
instructors because I don't know if you
all know this but there is a critical
shortage of teachers and Educators and
especially those in areas that are not
core content area and because of the St
Louis chess club collaboration we have
people who come in here working with
students who want to work with them
today with the experience of the
grandmas community outreach day I came
up and I'm like well what's a grandm and
they like oh you don't know what a
grandm is and they were able to explain
that and they recognize the importance
and the seriousness I mean it's a sport
it's a profession and so they're able to
see things out side of the sports that
we typically promote in school makes me
feel good because like learning stuff
like this will help me learn help me
build my problem solving skills help me
build strategy and like you know helping
my
[Music]
brain hello I'm women's Grand mastera I
will be creating content for grest store
follow us on social media and cap watch
more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis ches club.org to
claim your membership
today yeah um it's amazing what the club
has done for chess in general because I
mean it's already been 15 years and
they've done countless uh national
championships tournaments for juniors
helping around schools and they've just
grown the game so much across the United
States I think if I look at my own
career and I look at American chest in
general we're in a much better place
than we were 15 years ago and so the
contributions have been immense and of
course it's all thanks to Dr Jun
singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that S Club is
like a rock in the ocean of Chess and we
know that it's it's there it is there it
will be there I think it sense a hope
that the game of chess will always stay
afloat by the mere fact of its existence
I think it it it sends positive waves
across the
globe
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1,500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit World chess.com
org St Louis the chess capital of the
United States it also plays host to an
awardwinning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85,000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
seducation hello I'm women's grandm
ranoa I will take you behind the scenes
of the grand chest store follow us on
social media and don't miss out on
players interviews and more content from
the playing
Hall the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen singfield and Rex singfield the
the St Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Karen's cup and many more all
tournaments can be streamed via our
YouTube and twitch channels that also
include over 2,000 chess lectures for
anyone to enjoy become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments merchandise
discounts and so much more visit St
Louis chess club.org to claim your
membership
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chess
pce sitting outside our front door the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
familyfriendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please visit World
Chess h.org
[Music]
and we are back with our coverage of
round four of the sinkfield cup and well
the players they're giving it their all
today as they are fighting hard although
do you we're predicting maybe there
might be a few draws there in the mix
well definitely uh the players are
trying and they've uh had uh great
positions fighting positions but boy
accurate play in all of them as we see
our uh standings no results thus far Joy
no results uh so that means the
standings after round three are valid
and uh as you can see there haven't been
any decisive games in the tournament so
so far so everyone is at level pegging
and well players pegging is that is that
not that's not an American thing pegging
level pegging yeah level pegging very
specifically level level yeah okay you
you don't really want to be using that
without the words level nice um well for
those of you we were on break and we
were just having this thought between
ourselves this idea that we've been
doing our commentaries and the comes
four five six hours but on the playoff
day with nine players tied reverse we'll
be working for eight hours to resolve
the tie uh Peter we do again we have
some very nice imbalanced positions you
have one in front of you Onish giri and
he's missed the earlier moment with Rook
C5 I think that will be very ging for
him because he's made the Right Moves In
the wrong sequence now after Rook C8 had
he started with Rook C5 my impression is
still that the engine will hold this for
black but mvl not being an engine this
would have been very difficult and
instead he began with A4 and then he he
he sank into very deep thought here
probably realizing that M A5 shouldn't
be available but is available very
specifically because in all of these
positions as we were describing it's
very very important that F5 as you will
see here and also in the game after Rook
C5 KN fd4 F5 once again is very
confidently met by Knight E5 and black
is
assuming control and they have reached
the position where we're discussing
Yanka suggestion of Rook H5 also
happened though right down the whole
after after KN after Knight F4 Rook H5
attacking the pawn on H7 and also side
steping the Knight F5 counterplay so
reestablishing the idea of a four F5 and
now King F7 very strong move because
after Rook H7 King D6 The Rook has to go
to B7 and I was extoling the virtues of
the move Knight d8
but even something like Bishop takes A2
which does allow G4 which looks a bit
iffy for for the black king but you can
play something like F6 F5 it's very
sharp uh the machine says everything is
very equal here but this this is now a
proper mess once again like can bling F2
and pretend that maybe Rook G1 at some
point might be a threat or just asking
black to make a move and then reacting
to that move more favorably but seems to
be reasonably balanced now or once again
returning to this idea of Knight d8
because if you go Rook E7 uh The Rook
still comes into C2 because we've
overprotected the bishop on E6 and the
same applies to Rook B6 Rook C2 and now
the White Queen side is also Under
Pressure you can imagine this getting
slightly out of hand for white because
uh if like if black picks up on B2 A2 is
constantly hanging or if black let's say
gets to play B D5 Knight 86 black could
be better here oh no question about that
Bishop D5 Knight d8 E6 six definitely
has my attention and joy I just have to
say whole Rook H5 Rook H stuff three
words
fabulous nice as he goes uh Pawn hunting
but Knight d8 mvl and Rook C2 uh that's
one game that I think is uh really a
great game the other one which again
confounding to me Wesley so versus
Richie uh this game uh Wesley sank into
he went into a a deep thought and he did
end up playing once again one of your
suggestions of just maintain the if the
C4 Pawn is going to be a source of your
counterplay let me overprotect the C4
Pawn I would be gobbling that Bishop
with Knight takes C6 Rook takes C6 C5 is
mentioned I would be applauding my play
thinking you know I've done everything
right I've got the center under control
I've got got the two Bishops I've got
space uh confoundingly uh Wesley said
NOP I don't need that I will just do
what Joby will do I'll play Rook C1 I'll
drop back with the Knight with the I
idea of just defending the C4 overly and
the bishop on E2 I think there was one
variation uh Peter you had mentioned
where there was a weakness on A6 and we
can see that the bishop on E2 uh is uh
it's it's very important piece here I
just wanted to point out I briefly
because all of this all of these moves
came in basically just just now and I I
want to to check briefly why aren't we
picking up on B5 because it seems like
we're only really one move away from
complete stability in the center the
king isn't really very stuck uh the
bishop is already on E2 and it's a very
valuable Pawn because every single end
game will be massively favorable for us
if we preserve the queen side safe here
uh and in this position it is very very
specifically the move D6 D5 that gives
black counterplay uh because you would
maybe originally think that Queen V8 is
playable but after A2 A4 you have a
somewhat unpleasant choice you have this
temporary Queen sacrifice with the fork
on D3 but after King G King G2 Queen
takes C1 you aren't winning the B Pawn
quickly enough it probably gets picked
up with Knight f8 Knight D7 but this is
exactly the kind of an end game I was
referring to earlier you are very very
unhappy here with black with the Rook
coming into C1 the Knight coming to
D3 make make a couple of indifferent
moves here with black you're lost three
moves later no question about with the
with the King activity as well as Yanka
was saying this is just very very
pleasant for white exactly uh so D6 D5 I
think is critical here and white can
arguably ignore it you can play castles
you can play Knight F2 you can also play
e takes D5 because Queen takes D5 A4
you're probably doing well after e D5
the engine actually
cleverly includes Knight and this is a
kind of a typical compensation that you
see in these positions I think maybe for
the if you see it for the first time you
think white is a pawn up white also has
the bishop bear what's the problem and
yes these Knights look very beautiful
but are they really enough for a pawn
but black gets a lot of play Here There
is a kind of a Beno type play on The
Queen side continue if you don't mind
Bishop C5 exactly you know yeah I mean
we're a pawn up
let's
asked and answered any other questions
Joy why
actually que Queen D4 yeah of course it
was
yeah I I want I want to do something
clever okay but uh King I thought I was
being I thought I was being very smart
with Bishop D4 Bishop D4 coming in but
unfortunately after King H1 I I have to
resign which is not my ideal scenario
here que D4 Che of course is
significantly stronger and black is if
anyone is better here black gosh when
when I saw Bishop C5 I was so Chu me too
I was like you know that defends the
pawn on V4 protects our Bishop love
you're using English words chuffed want
you to feel right at home I mean these
are new Studios after all um I'm still
reeling from Level pegging uh by
the you
have to use these
days and there's also this position
where once again I want to say I don't
know if this boats well for the players
or not but we're guessing everything not
only did we guess F7 F6 yaser also said
I would like to play Queen B3 to have
the option of play C3 C4 and now after
Bishop C6 ala played Bishop D2 because
the engine is very unhappy about this by
the way the engine says it is time to
play 65 let's get it going and it very
much likes the black position because
currently we're not really threatening
e54 yet because after the recapture
there's there's a pin along this
diagonal but King h8 next and you will
start just rolling and the thing about
the structure is if he 54 followed by 65
lens black kind of gives M on the king
side with eyes closed right there's just
the the cut off between the queen side
and the King side is such that there's
just no way to bring enough Defenders
over and black just rolls over and gives
M so you have to do something more or
less immediately so we return to this
IDE C3 C uh first question why can't we
play E4 we can but very very
specifically C4 C5 might hold the
balance here because we are
reestablishing the idea of Bishop takes
C4 and shockingly after EF CD Queen
takes D6 we have this very beautiful
Pawn on F3 but the engine plays G3 here
and eventually I guess wins it somehow
there's also Bishop B4 coming in so this
is supposedly playable but you can see
already how move by move things become
how absolutely precisely white needs to
play to simply survive and E4 isn't the
best move if black very normally just
takes on C4 and goes King h8 the only
move to make his D4 D5 yes it closes
down the diagonal for now but after
Bishop D7 the things I said about the
king side once again give give me to
Tempe here to play F5 and E4 and you're
still going to be in tremendous amount
of trouble on the so this is very much
trending towards laner playing for a win
wow that whole F6 E5 and specifically in
the moment when your king is still on G8
uh I I find that counterintuitive
because I was thinking that the queen on
B3 was aiming against but it's not
enough black is so well coordinated by
this point that your C3 C4 it's still
your best play against E5 but it's
barely enough to equalize maybe do you
know something I've lost to my phone
many times like this
I've lost to my niece I've lost to my
I've lost to my phone soon it be your
toaster and then you'll be really upset
why in these positions where it goes E5
E4 I mean I I mean CU I was always under
the impression because I've been
studying The Exchange Caro for quite a
while now and I was always under the
pression that the bishop is really bad
on D7 and I had a lot of anxiety about
that but you know you know my life hack
where I get my computer my phone to uh
play the Black side of my openings it is
just completely completely thrashes me
by doing this type of thing yeah uh you
know a teenhood spent studying The
Exchange caroan has not been a wasted
life
no it's I mean I mean it's relevant for
every porn porn structure right you know
in the London system and maybe nothing
more but Queen git declined okay so this
game is aot interesting that E5 hasn't
landed yet lineer as usual is this is
move 18 lineer is both of them have
thought long and hard about things in
this game but right yeah ler not playing
E5 is is a bit mystifying because all of
his previous play was very much aimed at
playing E5 here Queen D7 uh allows white
to play Queen C2 I guess this is maybe
the reason why Queen D7 isn't great
because suddenly the best move machine
suggest here is going for this
position which is
might be proud of night on H I would be
proud of
night should never laugh at a position
yeah so not only is E5 strong E5 is also
semi forced so L better play it soonish
because calculations after A5 will be
very very uh difficult there's going to
be we still have 30 pieces left on the
board I he's played Queen D7 oh okay
inviting Queen C2 inviting Queen C2 yeah
by the way a very very big change just
occurred in the game between Wesley so
and Richard uh raor moroy bind like
position uh was followed up with what I
think is a very anti-position move after
the move of Knight B2 Richie took on C4
takes on C4 and I think everybody was
simply expecting the recapture uh B5
takes C4 not anticipating E6
E5 I mean I'm I I almost heard the cries
of the bishop on G7 and the bishop on G7
what are you doing you're shutting me
down you're blocking my view E7 E5 Peter
that don't like it's a stunning move I I
I I it wouldn't have been in my field of
vision please pick it up uh I mean
besides Knight F5 aren't we just in
tuming our Bishop on E7 no there's a
number of uh there's a number of issues
here uh even let's say if you completely
ignore the more Tactical possibilities
and you just make a quiet move like
Knight B3 and then you recapture with
the bishop okay these positions are
quite dangerous for black you you are
the reason he's played E5 here comparing
this to the position after takes takes
yes he gives himself the option of
playing Bishop B5 and he also and you
will notice that anti-position as it is
I think the problem the mistake came
earlier because in here the engine
suggests actively to playing e75 because
A6 is hanging and you need the move
Bishop B5 next move so he is trying to
improve on it by denying white what
would be the best Square in this
position which is E2 because then the
Knight will come to C3 so he's doing
something clever on on on a on a certain
level but what he's allowing you
correctly saying he's allowing Knight F5
although weirdly the engine says this is
tolerable after F takes C4 and it gets
messy a stronger move here in terms of
these kinds of intermas is
this and I'm pretty sure he is not
intending to play this position look
because this position just looks
terrible
uh positionally speaking we would like
to play 9 B6 9 D5 there is also
potentially a threat of A2 A4 Follow by
9 B6 which might be even stronger in
some cases for instance the engine makes
this weird looking move Bishop F6 but
it's very understandable to try to trade
our now completely ruined Bishop on the
G5 square and in response to this the
strongest reply is this and after Rook
C1 both takes C1 and queen takes C1
followed by after the trade we can play
something like Queen C6 Bishop G5 let's
say Bishop F2 and we end up in these
types of positions which are you know
you sometimes survive with black but
we're dominating but it's really really
unpleasant to play this that's terrible
it feels bad so my feeling is he's
intending to go for this Pawn sacrifice
after ab5 n D6 for instance Rook C1
Queen C1 and then the engine suggest
this very f funky looking move this page
stra very nice yeah but you're still not
equalizing even here uh because night
Tak of seven Follow by GH3 is suggested
as as a position that is better for
white also you can reply to this by
castling and after Queen takes D6 I can
spend some time picking up the Rook on
f8 although although you have to say
that maybe something like this is
actually absolutely dream scenario for
black you're down a lot of material but
the pieces you've got left actually good
pieces for once right this Knight will
be very strong on either of these two
squares the bishop also if it lands on
F4 will be quite strong this feels like
a position where despite being a full
exchange and pawn down you might be kind
of okay with black and after ab5 I just
want to mention that Knight D6 is strong
but maybe Knight B6 is even stronger mhm
provoking this trade and then just
playing positionally I want to either
lend this Knight on D5 or in case of F5
uh we can go into a position like this
where every single end game is winning
for white MH and it very much depends on
black developing some sort of
counterplay straight away in the next
three moves something needs to happen
because if we just stabilize if we
attack the pawn on B5 once it collapses
yeah if if the queen somehow attacks the
pawn on B5 and forces black to play Rook
B8 and there is no more count to play on
the king side you just lose maybe not
very fast but you just lose so yeah uh
reard is in trouble the question is
which of the very very attract options
uh Wesley will choose here yeah and we
shall see but n none of them is managing
their his time particularly convincingly
so this also looks like potential very
serious time very very uh strong
potential for a decisive game in this uh
but we have a a Twitter yeah we asked
and you guys asked answer exactly you
guys delivered and what have we done
this is from the grand chest tour which
oh this is a poll question we wanted ask
okay so which game will finish
decisively today and then against Maxine
Wesley against Richard ala Len Yan Fabi
well knowing what I know uh deep into
the game I'm going to go with the Wesley
Richard game just because I feel that
the current position on board is just so
strongly favorable favorable for Wesley
what about yourself you stole the words
right out of my mouth um I actually
think Wesley Rich it as well but um okay
I can't take yours so I'm gonna go for
Ali res L okay and I'll take weirdly
I'll take Anish Anish versus Maxim
because I think that one is heating up
very very nicely it's now a very sharp
end game mm and what did the answers I'm
looking for answers here the poll
we we're being victimized by the PO so
if you want to answer the poll go on to
Twitter go on or X as it's now called
Grand chess tour and uh our res pres an
expert also picked Wesley against
Richard I've said it and I said it
before I'll say it again bar is a very
intelligent
man I like the pause there
lry we didn't see Queen C this is the
second this is the second best move but
it still is a bit unclear to me why uh
Al chose not to play quein C2 because
this allows black perhaps to uh prepare
for for those threats better for
instance the move we were discussing in
in some of the previous positions Knight
F5 and the other Knight will not have to
go to h8 it will at least have the E7
Square available to it are the knights a
little bit messed up Peter go go ahead H
you do have Knight H4 but yes that was
my question blunder a piece here yeah
that was my question can we uh okay yeah
okay sneak a piece of so I guess I guess
it needs to go to H4 but this is this is
actually a pretty good Square supposedly
fine for black with the 65 still being
kind of hinted at and the Knight
completely safe on H4 true would it be
safe though the queen has done his job
on B3 can come back to D1 I can I can
stop you from playing Queen G4 while
also making the move I want to make
anyway so which was
touche yeah so yeah kind of an
interesting sequence there with ler very
much you know isoing a move he I think
clearly wanted to make
and then and then ala reasonably quickly
forgoing an option which we thought was
quite attractive you failed in the poll
you said Anish G mvl why what has what
has Chang failed what do you mean failed
failed I voted voted I want I want my
pin you know I voted I want my
pin that stuff happens in
Russia we're in a chess Studio you don't
get a is getting SP by the minute you
don't get a pin Knight E4 and suddenly
you got enthusiastic why what's going
well the move I like the most here
there's this Rook on B6 which isn't
really apart from attacking the pawn on
A6 but by this point I really don't care
about my remaining pawns with black I
want to launch an attack against the
white king exactly and in order to do
that I kind of would really like not to
have to worry about Rook D6 okay so I
start by cutting it off completely okay
and then my ideal next to moves are like
Bishop D5 followed by five
and if that lands kingside just
collapses and you will notice that Rook
takes A6 already isn't really on the on
on the screen because Bishop D5 complete
bottoming out of the evaluation here
white is in terrible terrible trouble F5
is a threat Knight E2 is a threat right
uh and now Rook E3 probably will be met
by either Knight F5 or King F5 is even
very strong the king joining the attack
here King saying you know I I can I can
support my my Army here from from the
front and
you after Knight C6 this is still
balanced apparently with a move like
Rook E3 not obvious to be able to meet
Bishop D5 check with okay yeah I mean
nobody's finding that me knight3 it says
Knight C3 box forced it says Knight C3
or resign basically you do have a rook
G3 check and here we see the point of
Rook E3 because Bishop takes G2 there is
now suddenly Rook G3 check fortunate and
if you take with the Rook you cannot
maintain this balance comfortably
because this is hanging you cannot leave
this diagonal without dropping The Rook
there is still Knight B4 or it even says
this is not so bad but obviously this is
not a dream Black is Black isn't really
looking to you know blunder a piece so
quickly but if if mvl plays Knight hc6
this is a very very sharp end game
exactly so I'm hopeful it it it's very
pre premature and I love the move Knight
d8 to C6 bringing all the people into
the party but a question I might ask
for you Peter is with the Knight on d8
for just a moment if I grab the stupid
Pawn on H3 oh okay Sor I'm I I mean I've
got a Perpetual check if yeah we start
by Rook F6 and then once again this very
very important move Rook E3 gotta trying
to get the lift to G3 and then white
might actually switch to trying to give
mate on the king side well that was
enough just still supposed to be around
equal but once you see the move Rook e 3
I think you kind of give up on this idea
but I love move Knight d8 C6 just
getting that a piece yeah off takes F6
exactly you the line we just showed the
line you you prompted prompted us to
show is a very good illustration and
andv plays Knight C6 by the way of
course of course uh Bishop H3 Bishop D5
this is maybe a threat now it's getting
spicy and is Rook E3 the only Move It
also says somehow H4 Bishop D5 H5 is
survivable uh but yeah I don't know King
H6 Knight takes F6 like how confident
would he be in a practical game playing
something like this oh my oh my God let
me show you the first slide Bishop Tak
G2 King H2 Knight F3 King G3 Knight E1
resigns
no oh no not resigns okay I want my
opponent wanded only move right to stop
me Knight takes you for threat is coming
back and reintroducing this idea and
this is somehow just completely well
actually check the board because uh
Anish has Tak Tak on A6 and M MV hasn't
played Bishop D5 Play Bishop D5 Bishop
D5 was kind of
winning he instantly takes on B2 this is
a bit surprising B2 he's still better
but he he just passed up what really
amounts to to a win well well first of
all to my way of thinking Bishop D5 is
really a g a dream a move cuz I want to
be on that diagonal and I loved your
king of five by the way bringing
honestly I I don't understand yeah this
seemed like a very very obvious uh thing
that you should you should at least be
considering because yeah like if this
works it probably wins is my point yes
but on the other hand is is irresistible
to grab extra material right true uh I I
I have to say that I would probably
fallen for Rook B2 as well after all it
is a Pawn on you're still better in fact
like decisions that white needs to make
here are not going to be very easy
currently best line is a four or five
check just I think to lure the bishop
away from the best diagonal wow it's
seriously it goes F5 Bishop F5 and there
are no tactics it just goes Knight D6
and says I have achieved something
because my Pawn on G2 is not going to be
attacked immediately this is the full
extent as I understand it of of of what
white is trying to achieve here just not
getting mated is the aspiration here
it's an important
aspiration not getting m it is we should
all aspire to avoid checkmates on the
other hand Joie when the computer is
just shedding material like this it just
goes to show that the minor pieces have
taken over it's no longer Rook versus
minor pieces the minor pieces are really
I have to say that rookie 3 is also
playable though is not e is Rook E3 is a
much more understandable move trying to
get it to G3 trying to defend your
position that way W honestly a very
uncharacteristic Miss by mvl because mvl
is unbelievably sharp in like short
calculations of has always been
something he was one of the best in the
world at so to see him completely Miss
such a such a shot is unusual you you
mentioned in one of the breaks that you
had been invited to a puzzle Rush
competition that featured Ray Robson da
nitzki and Christopher you in your
section no no not D no no no it was it
was Ray Robson Christopher youu and mvl
in your section and you had no chances
in the puzz my first match was against
ml which I lost very convincingly and
the reason I'm bringing this up now is I
had a very funny conversation with mvl
afterwards he said uh I was very unhappy
I played you first because it didn't
give me a proper warm-up I knew I will
beat you
[Laughter]
whatever and he's your good friend yeah
I wasn't offended like yeah other
imagine his enemies how how Peter gets
treated by people who don't like
I mean really likes the
man you didn't give him a proper warm-up
so for him Bishop D5 I would have I
would have taken him against against the
field sort of to find Bishop D5 and to
find it quickly and to play it
confidently so yeah it's a it's an
unusual one he generally doesn't miss
them even so Rook takes B2 it's still
got to be a a nice Advantage for
black having given the engine time to
think it is now suggesting this is
manageable I don't know if if it's only
F5 or Rook E3 maybe if I increase the
number of lines there will be something
else that is playable but those two now
I think those types of numbers are
pretty much conclusively draw with best
play draw with best play but I mean
we've seen the last five moves
featured not exactly best play so uh
this is maybe not as Joy where would you
like us to go yeah Peter mentioned the
was draw with best play so I'd love us
to go to the game Wesley against Richard
because there's been some radical
changes
there an exchange sacrifice so after the
move E5 Wesley's presented with some
really tempting opportunities Knight
takes D6 Knight to F5 that's a nice jump
Knight takes B5 and simply the slow
positional play Knight B3 and saying
look what you've done to your Bishop
you've you've given me an outpost you're
welcome to take my knight and then after
Bishop takes please do me a favor Play
Bishop B5 I'll probably trade I'll
castle and you'll suffer for the rest of
the game Richard said no suffering no
such thing yeah Rook C4 Bishop B5 F
sacrifice in exchange for not even a
pawn not even a pawn but trying to keep
the king in the center and my first
question to you yaser
is you're a pawn Grabber this is not a
pawn but
you it implies you like material are you
playing Rook back or are you playing
Knight A5 here or
I mean one one of those uh I like safe
Kings as well uh Knight A5 because my
first in was was as well yeah I can play
Knight A5 here and I'm better and the
engine actually doesn't disagree with us
at all it just says that the attack is
not sufficient it goes Rook C1 and says
there's my Approach come on
matal exactly Rook C1 and show me what
you got F5 let's go yeah it doesn't play
F5 shockingly it it does some weird
shuffles yeah and in in fact our reply
to Queen H4 check here suggests to me
that maybe we should consider Rook C2
because the reply to Queen H4 check in
this position is to play King D1 and
start running in that direction and the
way it runs for preference is Rook C2
followed by King C1 King B1 so perhaps
C2 is just originally a stronger Square
very much with this intention saying now
that you play D5 yeah I feel reasonably
confident I will not get mated around
the B1 Square so I can just start slow
slowly slowly by foot getting over
getting over to safety I mean and you're
saying the computer is not sorry uh is
not playing F5 no no it it does some
weird slow things like it plays Queen E7
King D1 Rook d8 King C1 Knight f8 and
then it pushes d65 That's Not My Vibe I
I'm not as good as that so my vibe would
have been actually to put the Rook on C3
okay as white as white because you know
I want still with the same Shuffle yeah
no I want to go A4 I want to go A4 and
then castle and castle and then Castle I
am a Mater let's check yes so we go A4
and this is done this is also very
up sign my
scy
clown I'm so
simplistic the one issue with this is
you the bishop the bishop the bishop
will drop back to B5 and it will take
you some time to make progress here
because black will have a pawn for the
exchange you'll I mean I'll play
something like Knight F6 Bishop drops
back to B5 I want to play perhaps Bishop
f8 Rook E6 and of course you're much
better of course but like if you add
white a Pawn on the a file here black
resigns so I would the the the proper
maximalist approach here is to try to
preserve everything you know because as
long as this is alive every single end
game is winning every single middle game
once your king is safe is winning and in
the meantime I don't know if they will
immediately find the repetition I just
want to we'll return to the sharp game
soon but nobody voted for this game
right and I think that's correct and uh
by way on the game between Yan and Fabby
an enormous number of moves have been
played what I thought was the Marquee
matchup for some reason the other games
you know stole all the Thunder and
they're now in a rook and two versus
rook and one that's a dead draw I'm
pretty sure they will they will find
some kind of repetition soon and just to
briefly show how they got here played
very very precisely from a certain point
onwards after Knight F6 uh played Rook
E5 a very good move A7 A6 here was
played by Fabi the point being uh I want
to illustrate this like you can play C6
here and if you if you play very naively
and do this this you might actually lose
this because the outside passer is very
rook and outside passer against two
minor pieces without a rook is
incredibly dangerous so what he's doing
by playing A6 he's saying in that very
final position with a Pawn on A6 I will
have Bishop B5 and you will never win it
exactly so this is taken off the board
uh Yan played F3 G4 here black played
Knight D7 Rook F5 check King G8 and now
if you play D6 you're actually allowing
for instance B6 among other things so
Yan just played C6 gave away his Pawn
gave away his pawn and now uh it feels
like if anyone is better it's probably
black but actually the cordination is
just not there the Rooks are very active
and this is also I think very easily uh
demonst by the choice of move fa did
here he just gave up his two pieces for
The Rook trans liquidating into exactly
the the position we have on our
screen Yan took on B5 took on D7 black
played Rook C3 Rook B3 forced the final
pawns off the board on uh the king side
and it feels like there will now be this
repetition with King H2 Rook H4 no Yan
is actually playing on we'll return to
this when they shake hands which they
will exactly draw uh going on here but
the other three games and Richie has
played D6 he play D6 D5 which is Rook C1
very interesting maybe maybe uh Wesley
was feeling uh kind of like what you're
were suggesting that he if I can get my
Pawn to A4 and Castle uh life will be
good but D6
D5 uh I noticed I noted that the engine
was doing a lot of Preparatory work he
was playing Rook E8 Knight F6 and then
going for D5 D5 right away uh Peter
can't I just
grab I think the point is we give a
check on H4 now Queen G5 is a bit
awkward actually it's still playable but
it's a bit awkward so we think we want
to play yeah the engine goes G3 Queen H3
it goes Queen G2 and says this is
nothing but from a purely human
perspective some position like
this you can see you can see this
becoming unclear in particular if like
if you add f e f and Knight F6 you start
liking
black not there with you though yet uh
go go go back to the position after G3
can
I can I try King F2 just to stop F5 I
mean I don't understand why I don't
understand why this is unclear but this
is like legitimately quite unclear now
the idea of G I was expecting Knight F6
I was too I didn't even think of G5 KN
of6 KN of six it doesn't like because
now it says after Quin G1 I will be able
to stabilize honestly I would also much
more expect something like this yeah
let's go some kind of a romantic
romantic idea of opening everything else
but there's no mate here you have to be
precise but there's no mate here it goes
very slowly it goes G5 goes G4 forces
you to open something up and in
particular break this little bit of
chain so that the Knight on H7 when it
does come to F6 will actually be
attacking something extraordinary and
white is still better it's not like this
is suddenly very very good for black but
this is a game and it prefers Queen G2
for whatever reason but I think it's
also very very concrete because after F5
it goes A4 Bishop takes A4 and queen A2
and these types of geometries I think
are incredibly missable very very
missable oh for sure and after Bishop PA
to yeah but it's just so calm I don't
know if anybody can play like this in an
actual fact it like it goes kn2 and then
just takes just takes on H6 and says I
want to play Queen F1 sir would you like
to trade Queens yeah yeah wow ice water
huh yeah but Queen D5 Queen H4 on the
board but I'm pretty sure the actual
game will look like nothing that I've
shown cuz those are those are very very
computerist VAR well for for for me the
move Bishop F2 Queen G5 I don't really
want to face he's play G3 already yeah
so I'm thinking G3 is pretty much
obliged and I don't see a better move
than Queen H3 your queen has just no
squares have to put it on H3 this is why
you play D5 Queen H4 I'm exactly yeah by
the way this is move 24 so 16 to make uh
17 minutes for Wesley uh 18 minutes for
rard uh this is probably not the last
difficult calculation they'll have to
make so this is potentially a quite a
nailbiter on our hands uh and then
finally we've got a drop in on the game
between Ali Raza and L lanir we when we
left it we'd seen the move H4 joy and we
kind of thought that was a little bit of
a head scratcher cuz we expect have
happened many things uh Rook a E8 H5
going
for uh mate yeah a very very cute move
Bishop B1 there establishing the uh the
the battery yeah the battery on the B1
H7 diagonal okay uh Bishop dropped back
uh to Queen C2 in the current
position any sane human being will play
F5 apparently G6 is also playable but I
don't think anybody does that that would
be that would be a very strange move to
see in a practical game I'm expecting a
five if I had a student who played G6
you would say no I would say have a nice
life goodbye don't return to
class G6 okay I'm in F5 okay so what's
happening after F5 then a five it
switches to positional play now we have
this very nice Square on a five to aim
for in particular because we did Knight
the Black Knight the square on G6 so
even let's say if the trade on E5
happens right black can't chase this
Rook away immediately this particular
position honestly weirdly to my eyes the
engine suggests and Yanka was very very
Ono with the idea of bringing this6 I
tell you that structure the Knight wants
to be on D6 I'm I'm still kind of
shocked this isn't better for white like
I would be I would definitely start by
thinking I must be better here but the
Knight gets to E4 and then you play
Queen F7 and actually H5 becomes a bit
say why is white better here I would be
rubbing my hands gar Black's probably
but we are absolutely not obliged to
play Knight E5 early we can start by
let's say playing Knight one D2 and then
it also includes B4 very often actually
B4 and A6 will be included so let's just
put this on the board we go one Knight
one D2 We often will play Queen D1
perhaps even Bishop D3 because now with
this setup on the queen side it's very
difficult for black to do very on the
king side it will be very difficult for
black to do anything and white can now
improve for quite some time without G G
I think I think that's the only the only
source of counterplay you do have but
the engine even says you can ignore
it wait for G4 play kn5 then and perhaps
even we will be recapturing with the D
pawn and putting the light on D4 you
know uh hilarity did you expect this
though King King F7 well uh lanir isn't
dismissed from
class the question of his return well he
has he has a point right the queen goes
to H7 well you just go F5 F5 and then
you wi win the tra exactly she's setting
up setting up a bit of a chipo here what
I wanted to say is today uh they're
using so many tools and so many software
and puzzle rush and things like this I'm
really look looking forward to the time
that they give us a set number of games
and say please guess the ratings of the
two players this exists as a party game
already right does it oh fabulous I I
mean I have to get out more that's clear
what's it called guess my R guess your R
guess guess the rating actually that
would be a perfect name for for the game
we're talking about but I'm looking at
this position of after streams this
occasionally right
yeah people do this okay uh looking at
White pieces the bishop on B1 the KN on
F1 I mean the bishop on C6 the Knight on
E7 it's like the Strategic misplacement
of almost all the minor pieces suggest
to me that these players are don't have
the highest
ratings I would disagree VI with the
bishop on the Knight on E1 and Knight on
E7 and Knight on F1 Bishop on D1 I think
this is this is quite clearly a game
between two strong players to be honest
yeah I'm I'm going to do terrible at
guess the game and guess but King
F7 uh Peter King F7 I wouldn't have
guessed that move I not a huge fan no no
I I'm a big big fan athetic reasons let
me let me let me rephrase that athe let
me rephrase that I'm a huge fan it's not
a good
man there you have it h those the things
those the things I coexist perfectly
peacefully uh no okay first of all Queen
H7 we show that5 is very strong what it
does is it pretty much always includes
B4 A6 because there's really no reason
not to include it and now let's say
something like Knight H4 okay with the
idea of perhaps bringing the other one
over to F3 we will play Queen E2 at some
point n G6 will be an annoying threat
for the rest of the game in fact it
pretty much provokes F5 because
eventually you'll have to play F5 and
then you have to ask yourself why put my
I played King F7 well Queen D6 first
okay your own Checkmate by the way on
H2 not not G6 is legitimately a very
annoying threat here because you pretty
much have to play Rook G8 or give up the
exchange and then I can play something
like Queen E2 or queen D1 I don't know
why it chooses Queen D1 but like
bringing the queen over to F3 then
perhaps even Rook E2 E2 and you're
you're very very restricted now in in
what what you can aim for in this
position for black no
with this this is the moment the moment
black position has started you know
being being in danger I think had he
played A5 he would still be within the
margins but after King of7 with 10
minutes against ala also ala will will
be very practical against against Joy
I've got news for you varujan changing
his poll numbers and he's saying three
decisive games expecting that Yan and uh
um uh Fabby have already RW they they
haven't but they will soon yeah draw and
F is doing it the right way because he
he basically he waited for the opportune
moment and then just gave up the G Pawn
by playing G6 G5 here right um yeah
we'll see it in a moment yeah and
they're about uh and uh yeah Yan is
playing it out but the important thing
here is that Yan doesn't think for 25
minutes somewhere cuz they both they
both know what this is as long as you
play quickly nobody is going to object
to you playing this out right so you go
Rook A5 King H4 Rook B5 G5 and then you
go behind yeah yeah and there's
absolutely no difference between one and
two G Pawns in this position it's a very
comfortable draw yeah and actually the G
pawns are not great pawns either not at
all and even something called the back
rank defense will work okay King comes
up to H4 yeah I think actually the the
the the best troll yes from Hikaru oh
Hikaru that's a different conversation
uh the the best troll from Fabiano's
side here would actually be to allow the
king all the way to H6 which I suspect
is still a draw although you have to be
careful my gosh I would not want to yeah
you probably you probably don't want to
test that you probably don't want to
test uh Knight G3 uh by Ali Razer I
really and the king is going backwards
so this is uh this is where the draw
will be incoming yeah I'm expecting uh
some checks at the moment no uh just
simply Rook B4 I I like the move Knight
H4 by uh Ali Raza very much because as
we see the players making a repetition
reping the position and so a draw will
be incoming and there we can see draw
has been offered well you're not allowed
to offer a draw but uh Fabiano stops the
clock calls over the Arbiter and yeah
very accurate game
yeah very accurate let's go straight to
the king F7 KN G3 was chosen bya which
is a bit of a weird Square to be honest
because I'm I'm not sure what it you're
developing a piece you're putting it on
a more active more forward square but
where is it going from here I really
like this idea that we were discussing
of putting it on H4 and perhaps lifting
the other one to F3 because on F3 I
think it controlled a lot more important
squares n G3 and quickly plays Rook G8 a
move I don't quite understand I guess he
actually wants to play G5 but I am
really first and then G6 and by the way
seems like there was a tactical reason
to play Knight G3 because my engine
suddenly is flashing up and saying I can
play Queen H7 now so what changed after
F5 we now have Bishop takes F5
apparently and if e takes a five Knight
takes a five and you
Knight yeah important tactic here Queen
F5 instantly loses to Rook takes
E7 C destroying the defender of the
queen so Knight takes Queen G6 King f8
and this is better for white because
only move Queen F7 otherwise he get
checked from E1 so Queen F7 here you
will have to make an incredibly awkward
move Bishop B8 then The Rook comes in
and this is uh good for white although
not strictly speaking winning I don't
know if if if if n93 was played with
that intention I don't know if it's even
practical for ala to try to calculate
all of this because his position I think
remains good even if he doesn't exactly
uh but it's an option that has been
presented to him here uh after Rook G8
can we at least guess Knight H4 in this
current position uh Peter it's softer
than it well it does provoke a five but
we did sort of misplace this night it
really doesn't belong on G3 we'd love
the Abracadabra variation wouldn't we
yeah exactly yes yeah exactly can we do
this please and Wesley so is up an
exchange is that still the case he still
is very much up the exchange and the
position is still very very unbalanced
with the King on F2 exactly so let's
quickly rewind see how so we did see uh
Queen H G3 the queen drop back it didn't
go to H3 which was our main line Queen
H3 was our May uh give me the pawn on F3
you can't have it Rook d8 Queen B7 Rook
D3 trade of Queens well this must be I
guess with the intention of Knight G5 no
it it very much hinges of what on what
happens after Knight G5 so I go Rook
check it's always nice to include a yeah
the Knight is on G5 so the first move
that comes to mind is you want to
preserve you have Knight H3 okay I
understand suddenly King H7 Bishop
E3 H3 is very strong it is completely
winning for white but for a different
reason you can do it you can do it in in
two in two very similar but slightly
different ways uh you can start with H4
or you can start with Rook ag1 you just
the the key to understanding this
position is realizing that if black
takes one3 with a rook that Rook will no
longer really have any squares and we
will be able to attack and probably even
win it it'll be a little stuck so yeah
so two ways of dealing with this is
starting with H4 which after Knight
Knight takes F3 we can play Rook h D1
and another thing to say about this
position once we remove this Rook once
it gets traded off the board black is
completely helpless we are an exchange
up there's no technical problems
converting this whatsoever right and if
Rook takes F3 after King G2 black will
have to give up for more material the
engine prefers this but you're not
saving this position it's a very
romantic idea you know two Bishops very
nice structure but you two exchanges
down right this is never ever going to
be enough actually after a
the Rooks are going to get traded off
whatever happens yes and the other way
to do exactly exactly the same thing to
start with Rook HD1 I think that's maybe
the which absolutely forces Rook F3 now
we go King G2 the threat of H4 is very
strong if you play Rook F6 you run into
Bishop d8 which is also not a
particularly nice picture so yeah as
long as Wesley understands that Rook
takes F3 is a bit of a fake threat here
he will he will win right wow okay so uh
uh we do have our poll we asked you to
guess where the decisive games are going
to be for today and the answers are
envelope please Jo yes and well well we
see Anish Maxine
21.3% will think it would be decisive
Wesley Richard is definitely up there
Yan Fabiano though that was 37% 30%
reading comprehension
reading comprehension people we did not
ask which game will end in a draw
today which game will finish decisively
uh i' remind me not to ask a friend ask
the
audience uh thank you for participating
37.7 yeah I know and do remember that if
you want do you think they were trolling
us with that answer I think this I think
they were
because that was heading for a draw for
a long time yeah well or never or or the
other version which I already which I
already voiced very nice people people
are unused to reading okay but uh can we
go over to Anish giri against Maxim
vasra because Anish found one of the two
best lines by the way it seems to be
heading towards a draw now oh my because
mvl after 96 he he thought for quite
some time the F5 VAR did not find
anything stronger than Bishop takes H3
the engine suggests he could have still
played on with Bishop D3 and then
something like Bishop B1 and and to be
prepared to go to the H file here but I
guess he didn't really particularly
fancy the idea of at some point
blundering group h8 M result game no but
currently we're threatening the fork and
we're not actually getting mated here
black is playing for a win at least a
little bit but it's understandable that
he didn't want to really get too
involved with this uh so he went Bishop
takes H3 and unfortunately for him white
can just recapture and here the white
king is forced into F1 just otherwise a
mate that's been around since the
seventh century that's not mate Arabian
mate yes they've already repeated once
and if you could somehow bring the other
Knight into the like if you could in
this position play play something like
Knight F4 or Knight Knight H5 maybe even
stronger right you would be winning but
if you play 9 D4 it doesn't throw away
the draw because this pet is always
going to be here okay in fact I suspect
he will play something like this just to
check what Anish does in response Knight
E4 no then I can lose a rook right now
we've lost yeah yeah and now I've lost
the
rook in fact it's mate an eight with
this very beautiful move 9 G4 yeah made
eight you got to stop you got to stop
Rook H2 coming your way but something
like Rook
E3 something and looks like yeah they've
shaken hands there does look like they
looks a draw Knight
H2
F3 and and an explaining what's happened
perhaps very verbally too like very and
maybe you know he was talking about I
know I think he's gesticulating that he
should have played Rook C5 and then Rook
H5 and then and only then
F4 you see for Anish this must be very
un unwanted feelings I want to say
because he had he had prepped this uh
very very nicely he got his prep and he
mixed it up he obviously intended Rook
C5 followed by F4 played F4 first Peter
and
uh lost some pretty impressive
preparation I want say yeah I it's a
very very unpleasant feeling when you
you actually get something onto the
board which you clearly looked at and
your opponent hasn't and it's a very
spectacular line as well but in a weird
way maybe the way the game finished will
sort of make him more at peace with it
because he also gained half a point you
know like he he will feel that maybe he
lost half a point but he also gained
half a point because he was borderline
losing there after takes A6 Bishop D5 so
yeah well very mixed back for him yeah
Joy way in on that so who do you think
uh did better in with the haing of the
point oh I think Anish will be very
annoyed because be very annoyed
absolutely because you he wasted good
prep as you said and uh let's remind
ourselves of the round four results was
a draw in the end between Anish giri and
Maxine Vash lra also a draw between Yana
pomi and Fabiana Carana but in the games
between wesy so and Richard raport and
Ali Resa fuja and against dingz
everything is still to play for yeah
well I do think that Wesley is the big
favorite but I want to forcibly remind
you Jo V in this game between H giri and
VL and VL my pick let me just remind I
picked mvl to win the event right oh
okay okay I thought you were talking
about the votes yeah well that too right
but someone's out of the face yeah
exactly but that move Bishop D5 and
Anish might have R you know rued the
moment that he played F4 because
suddenly that Bishop uh eyeballing at
the pawn on G2 the big threat King F5 I
know and2 and 92 check and Knight E2
check and Knight takes F4 so Bishop D5
and we think that was a winning moment
for Rook takes B2 surprisingly and a lot
of credit actually has to go to Anish
for uh you know recovering his composure
and finding all the defensive moves
after Rook takes B2 because that
position was still difficult to play and
still very very losable for white but
easily yeah F5 was a after after a
sequence where he was we have to say
outplayed frankly right from that moment
on he he regained his composure played
very very good chess and saved the game
uh as for the remaining two games being
everything to play for I would disagree
from the other side I think this one is
about to about to be over yeah wle did
play H4 and once this lands on the board
the choices are so ugly for black H4 has
been played right and the problem is
that after we play Knight takes F3 we
really don't have much of a choice Rook
D1 is going to force our hands to trade
Rooks no I think I think if you don't
design here you probably actually go for
this line because at least this way
you've destroyed the majority on the
queen side there is no immediate way for
white to create a passer and there is
this beautiful situation with yeah he's
gone Rook F3 he will take on B3 here I'm
pretty sure Rook F6 Bishop d8 is even
more ugly so I think Rook B3 is the move
so just from the Practical perspective
you have to uh uh jettison a second
exchange for some is it so bad though
right it is because the king is with the
king in a center with better cination it
would have been a legitimate drawing
attempt but with the King on G8 and the
Rooks coming in very very quickly after
Knight takes E4 I will give a check for
instance after King H7 I'll play Rook
C7 and you will have to start dropping
pawns because you can't really play F5
because that will uh completely
disconnect your uh your pieces and once
the second Rook lands on the seventh the
game will end you can't really play King
G8 because Rook D1 d8 will win on the
spot the best move here is G5 Rook F7
King G six but really once once you
start dropping dropping G5 is the best
move yeah that's and Rook F7 even isn't
even the strongest you can start with
rookie one which is even harsher oh my
mhm no it's it's just very very bad oh
my rookie one looks like a very
attractive move certainly but wow if you
have to start jetting pawns Joy I'm
sorry to say it's not our day I I I mean
I would be playing F7 F6 and hoping that
you know I would be able to reroute my
Knight to F5 and you know try to put up
some kind of after do do you have very
many legal moves though I know that's
the other issue is uh you don't let my
knight get back into the game Rook D1
King maybe G5 here though yeah King H6
just to get out of the pin3
check mean Bishop E3 check is that so I
mean is well at least I should play G5
so that I can play King G6 and not
suffer the consequences of yet another
pit what I will say about this is I
think in Practical terms the easiest way
to win this position is to play Rook 1
D7 and just give back an exchange yeah
because then the A6 Pawn will fall in
about two moves and then I will Queen
the B Pawn Rook D7 Bishop D7 Rook D7
Rook A7 next move against anything take
grab the pawn and there we go Rook takes
B3 and the moment white creates a passer
on the queen side the game basically
ends good point yeah see that's actually
one of the things I didn't understand
until I understood it is being an
exchange up means that we can give an
exchange back a lot easier
yes yeah it's it's a famous quote which
normally is used in in relation to the
advantage of the two Bishops but is also
extremely true about the advantage of
the two exchanges it's just that you
don't get it as often exactly night
takes E4 we're expecting and Richie is
just hoping that uh Wesley doesn't put
together uh the winning sequence which
leaves our other game yes and this my
pick when it came to having a decisive
game today ad Resa against lenia
Dominguez and we see Knight H4 and F5 on
the board and here there is everything
to play
for this one is very very sharp uh PA is
on B3 yeah he played B he didn't even
play B4 he played B3 which is a very
unusual choice I guess he wanted to make
sure it never hang the pawn never hangs
on four and also perhaps he wants to
introduce the idea of Rook A2 E2 without
commit without committing to too much on
the queen side I would still put it on
before though right okay I'm still uh
confused so now after F5 what are we
trying to do Joy are we trying to play
HG and trade or we yeah I think so or
are we trying to go Knight back to F3 to
E5 I'll step away from the board because
otherwise I will be I will be way
influencer yeah
um I I'm thinking that perhaps you don't
take on H5 immediately but you just have
that in the air it's perhaps time to
start well our Queen Bishop makes no no
sense right our Queen on C2 and Bishop
on B1 we're hitting so a rook on A1 is
doing nothing if you want to start with
Rook E2 I that's fine if you want to go
Queen D1 with the idea Rook A2 Queen E2
um but uh wh which piece unravel moment
would you start
with I think I would probably
go move the queen out of the way I love
that uh for me I love pinning my
opponent so when I play a move like
Queen D1 in my mind the image I'm having
is I want to take on G6 very much so
Knight takes G6 and then be a boss and
play Queen H5 I love as much as I hate
being in pins I love pinning my opponent
so for me Queen D1 without B3 by the way
or with B4 he returned the Knight which
is four
to I can't guess any of the moves
actually yeah Knight F3 Peter in this
particular game here we're we're not
great not even close king7 this is such
an unusual structure that I think the
players are also very much off off the
autopilot and having to think about
every single decision this is a
yeah I guess white is still better but
I'd be a bit worried about allowing GH
and then perhaps black will develop some
sort of counterplay against along the G
file but which is why he played King F7
in the first place he was dreaming but I
suspect ala is yeah GH played instantly
by by the year with six minutes on his
clock to seven minutes for Ali Rea which
uh yeah the the machine I I'm pretty
sure will will disagree with but for
let's try and do the last 15 minutes of
this game without consulting the machine
for once I'm going to stay here and not
look at it so are we playing Queen D2 uh
we're we're inviting Bishop takes G3 but
we anticipate that that's not a very
good idea because the Knight will be a I
actually wanted to ask you I mean how
stupid is n takes H5 I understand we we
don't have to but my my argument here
would be I want to play Queen D2 exactly
I want to uh ask you whether you care
about your H6 I you probably do care and
if I force you to and he does play
Knight takes H5 if I force you to play
Rook G6 I will have Knight F4 with Tempo
precisely um wait one second can I not
do moves like Knight G6 you can yeah
maybe you should start with that but
after Knight G6 once again I'm starting
with either Queen C1 or queen D2 the
argument for Queen C1 would be to free
up the second rank to play Rook A2 Rook
E2 later that would be my my somewhat
that would be the argument somewhat over
over clever argument I think it's a bit
artificial yeah but failing the idea
that we actually need to do anything
other than get our Queen towards the H6
pawn queen D2 and ask a very Salient
question by the way if I take on H6 it's
not just that I'm winning a pawn I'm
also winning n G5 Queen H7 there's a lot
of threats it feels like in this
position you're more or less obliged to
play Rook h8 and then your G file is
that's an accomplishment I've chased you
off the G file mhm and I feel like uh
Bishop D3 Rook e Rook E2 Rook e one Ian
there plenty's plenty here has really
picked up the initiative in this case by
the way which is why I I don't think G
was that great to be honest if I am
forcing Rook h8 then I uh a big fan of
Rook A2 and Rook E2 and putting my queen
on C1 and just accelerating that
position that we had exactly and you see
lineer took took GH because he
absolutely he desperately wants to have
something to do on the king side he
didn't want to defend a passive position
he had the option of playing G5 and sort
of closing the king side instead but
then he really has no threats and he was
I guess not really that happy about you
know having just to hold this yeah maybe
uh this position honestly the more we
discuss GH the more it feels to me that
we're opening up the king site to get
attacked not to create an attack
ourselves yeah that's also one of the
one of the problems Bobby Fisher family
said to get squares you got to give them
sometimes you you open up the position
to get an attack and you're the one
who's gifted your opponent the attack
sorry I was just I was just going to say
um okay bearing in mind that Queen D2 is
an unpleasant threat maybe you can go
Rook Rook G6 Rook to G6 and try to
defend everything that way we are
inviting Knight E5 and then he's G4 four
yeah I was I was wondering about that
and with a very spectacular idea which
I'm sure doesn't work but I really want
to show it on the board G4 let's say we
go Queen G2 okay I wanted to play King
G6 and say I you know I I will I will
launch a Counterattack here by by going
after this Knight on H5 or at least
forcing it to G3 where at least it will
not be coming to F4 anymore I think I
think forcing white to play Knight G3 is
an achievement here an achievement I'm
just worried that you might not achieve
what you're Abol I am also not
particularly confident
like after Knight E5 check are you going
H5 I'm taking I'm Tak I'm taking on E5
first and then I'm taking on H5 and I'm
claiming I'm not mated yet and maybe I
will never be who knows you know I me
this be proud be proud stranger things
have happened okay King oh but you can
play Rook E3
we where here or after Knight E5 you can
do it here King takes H5 huh King takes
H5 then the and then my point
was kn5 H H3 beautiful the Rover Knight
E5 Bishop E5 Rook H3 check Rook H3 but
you still I still run towards F7 there
might not be mate it's a very beautiful
idea but there might not be mate at the
end of it King G6 Queen H6 King F7 so
I'm a piece down what do I got for it I
get a pawn well you're currently two
downs you have to take on E5 right and
then I Knight G8 is a move Rook G6 is a
move it feels like I am actually
escaping with my life here
shocking yeah it does feel like that
doesn't it it's like a squirrel who's
grabbed a nut and run home with with the
goodies which I think probably prompts
us to discuss
95 no but 95 check immediately is also
not that clear I like Rook G4 Rook G4
introduces it introduces this you know
very very tasty level of insanity to the
position in particular with the idea of
King G6 to follow it up and I think this
is what he's intending because let's say
if you play Queen G2 Rook EEG G8 yeah
can I take on I'm pretty sure we can
take on H6 and allow you Rook takes G2
because I don't think Rook takes G2 does
very much and the Queen on H6 does a lot
uh Rook takes G2 it's always nice when
you when you capture such a beautiful
Pawn Shield King F1 but after King F1
you are facing some pretty harsh music a
check yeah it's just a check check I
have to check Bishop B5 check isn't made
but it isn't so you probably have to put
a rook on G6 I will give a check from H7
then I will consider my
options well yes Queen H7 I guess you go
to f8 yeah you have to go to f8 cuz
otherwise Knight F6 no not not yet but
it will be in the air yeah I think f8
I'll fall for it I'll go to F although
honestly I said the queen on H6 does a
lot but in this particular position I'm
so far struggling to win any kind of a
blow let alone a killing blow you know
it's it's time to play Bishop D3 King E2
rookie it's been
slow
motion we have to mention that we we're
having this fun with somebody else's
pieces yes we are with no pressure
whatsoever they are playing this
position on four minutes for 12 moves
and a lot of pressure on them in
particular on ala because ala needs to
nail down that rating spot so he would
very much like to win this game okay
let's let's start with the most mundane
and obvious 95 check the problem is take
it yeah we will have to take it but then
you I don't think you can confid take
yes I I I I was about to say I I prefer
to take with the Rook uh the problem
with taking with the pawn joke5 D4
exactly I'm ready for Knight F6 and you
know and a handshake but this move d4
rattles me desperately Queen can jump to
D5 and I would be afraid this this looks
very unclear and I can show a very
spectacular line here so you go Knight
F6 anyway Rook G2 King F1 and second I
thought we are attacking a lot of
material here including the queen yeah
but I I think maybe Rook G8 after King
F1 is pretty good oh my God and if you
go to Knight D7 I want to play Bishop F3
Bishop F3 yes so first of all let me put
my king on F1 like a good boy uh Rook to
G8 go ahead and take the queen and we do
have Queen D2 come on if we see Bishop
if we see King G6 I'm pretty sure do do
we throw coins at lanir do we throw
coins at
Peter they may be copper coins I I'm not
throw a coin to your coin and the
fountain uh so Queen D2 on the board
King G6 that would be well King F7
was was I think that would be there
would be a way oh and uh yeah we're just
going to interrupt you there because we
have our first decisive result Wesley so
had has beaten Richard report it took us
15 games right to get a lot of games wow
but uh we are here and you can see the
tble exchange sacrifice did not deliver
the goods as you were saying Peter is
just not even Clos the the the exchanges
uh are just too strong so the the
deadlock finally has been broken right
the curse has been lifted the curse has
been lifted and floodgates have been
opened I'll stop it
if you say The Parting of the
sea we are we are in biblical territory
epic epic very regrettably I mean we we
guessed the moves but they were not the
moves we wanted to guess yes Queen D2
king6 not played instead Rook EEG
G8 W on the board Queen takes H6 on the
board
yes oh boy where I mean the floodgates
could be opening the Seas could be
parting it's amazing everybody yes uh
Queen takes H6 and what are the clock
times okay well both players are around
the 3 minute Mark 3 minutes Mark 350 and
yeah Rook G2 will be played I'm pretty
sure King F1 is the choice King H1 just
looks wrong and uh on every level yeah
and I suspect Rook 2 G6 is the move here
there are some others you can name like
Rook a G6 I don't think loses on the SP
but I think I mean you can you can
choose you can choose the other Rook I
think no but they're just The Rook on G2
is in the way yeah but it looks it looks
wrong right it looks correct to have
your of course your Rooks control as
many squares as possible around youring
and and the further the worse the time
trouble the more the natural moves can
be expected and this is much more of a
natural for a second there I was
wondering if in this position 9 G5 chck
is very strong but there is no
particular followup after Rook G5 Queen
F6 King
E8 see that because it's not
I mean you do have Rook takes E6
crashing but then Rook H5 and we're kind
of running out of uh bullets you know
well if you're going to take all the
ammo out of the position that does hurt
that is hurtful yes uh agreed uh Peter
you just that's too many pieces uh no
Knight f f but Queen H7 check King f8 we
more or less stopped here but we didn't
come to a conclusion a judgment give me
your best judgment Joy would you like
white would you you like black why well
I think black is fine the Knight on E7
is such a great
defender I want to make a prediction for
the move in this position I think he'll
play Bishop G3 Rook G6 on the board as
expected he will play Queen
H and you think should they reach this
position Bishop D3 and then give me your
best judgment do you prefer white black
why I think I'm probably still
preferring white here because shocking
and maybe not so shockingly the white
king is still the safer of the two it
it's going to be quite comfortable on E2
in fact King E2 probably is the next
move it might even be but is it so safe
I mean I've got B5 ideas in the air yeah
but that's very far away I don't need to
react to B5 I like A5 Bishop B5 I will
have to answer questions but I don't
have to react to B5 at all I can play
kingu B takes a and play something like
the players are racing to the position
that we're uh uh trying to make a
judgment on I'm kind of preferring black
because I'm seeing the move knight uh to
C8 if I can force the trade of queens
and you do but I I I don't think this
position is so great for you I go King
E2 here I go Rook h8 or Rook yeah yeah
one short yeah I thought I would be in
time to play Knight E5 but I'm not right
I am not if you could play Knight E5 and
Knight F4 I might have to
resign Oh no you're absolutely right I
was I was I I misjudged the then be here
so King E2 is just a massive mistake I
have to play knight5 immediately after
the GN trade knight5 immediately okay
now I
do I do have a rook
check followed by and our producers are
telling you telling us the current
position contains a very strong move for
ala uh which is the which is the move
Knight H4 just trying to shift the Rook
away from G6 uh allowing inviting Rook
G1 allowing Rook G1 check is not going
to be such an easy move to make over
over two minutes three minutes on your
clock Joy yep three minutes would you be
reaching for your knight on Knight to go
to H4 away from your King well I feel
that white has to do something right now
so maybe B Bop d33 as that's such a
natural move I mean if
you're you you know you reach positions
with a little time on your clock and a
move like Bishop D3 followed by King E2
feels so natural but I think Knight E
Knight Knight E5 is actually such a huge
threat sorry I gonna say in fact because
of Knight E5 being such a huge threat
Knight C8 is the only move only move in
this position both knight5 and now in
particular Knight H4 is much stronger
even than on the previous move because
our Rooks are connected at last yeah so
yeah laner has to play Knight C8 but I'm
pretty sure he will play Knight C8
because he just doesn't have very very
many moves to choose from if we're
entirely honest yeah yeah the
Alternatives all look terrible and uh
that move Knight Knight C8 Jo after you
see the move Knight C8 you understand
the Knight really wants to get to E4 but
I think it's a timing problem right you
can't get it there I get Knight E5 first
right uh What uh what Peter wanted to do
was encourage Rook G1 check he wants to
play Knight E5 followed by Knight F4 and
make this beautiful positional uh
acclamation uh that you've got a
this this is not so clear I don't think
because youve got Bishop takes Knight
Bishop takes E5 F B5 D is the only move
of course and now Knight F6 is on the
agenda
and played with 1 minute 40 seconds on
his clock he gets the 30 second bonus so
his clock is up to two what move number
are they on they are move 33 so
there be playing his
I'm just going to update my board here
everybody there's not very much to
choose from so the Queens are coming off
and now very important moment for alza
he needs to recognize that the Knight on
H5 will be will be attacked if you don't
play Knight E5 immediately right so it's
I it feels like it's absolutely time to
play it right this moment or you might
never yeah there it is E5 there it is I
me y's choice is very binary here you
can include Rook G1 Rook takes C1 I
don't know if that improves position or
not one thing it does do is it gives you
the option of not taking on E5 in the
end this is what I was looking at giving
giving this check on G1 taking on E1 and
then perhaps playing something like
Bishop E8 Bishop E8 or something along
those lines but Knight F6 is still quite
annoying in those positions well okay so
so we'll go let's say King D7 and we'll
we'll make a this drops oh so no here
you're right I can't do it I have to
play Bishop E8
yeah if I don't want to play Bishop
takes E5 I me so Bishop E8 Knight F4 or
knight6 I I'm I'm not sure Knight F6
isn't strong but Knight F4 is very very
logical as well because you want Rook H1
and or King G2 even if you don't take on
E5 now King G2 will also be a very
unpleasant move to face no it feels like
the that the it's oneway traffic here
that that the knights are just simply uh
Superior so from our current position
that we do have
and by the way did you notice that uh a
little flare on that move Knight E5 by
Ali Raza just at the end he's got this
kind of graceful hand move L takes D
will happen
immediately as this now does give him
the protected Square F6 um I don't know
but to my eyes White's beginning to take
over uh Knight F6 Knight F4 King E2 I
see a lot of is currently not the threat
it's very specifically Knight F6 so I'm
looking at something like Rook h8 okay
Knight F6 because Knight F4 Rook G4 is
just bad King and King E7 for instance
yeah and trying to perhaps uh smoke it
out later or maybe there will be even
some positions in which I will not be
that unhappy about the exchange
sacrifice but maybe not yeah king2 is
very logical I want to challenge the
open H file or open G file for that
moment this is not a lot of fun for
black still but now you have the chance
to get your Knights to a good Square
yeah not not possible not possible not
yet it's close but not not quite I need
to move the
bishop um yeah Bishop Bishop D but then
I was worried about rook and then
because what I really wanted was Knight
D6
oh you're so crafty Knight D6 uh after
trading Rooks or something of that
nature and the idea is that the Knight
can can jump and
or actually you know to go Knight F7
just to hold the position tight Oh Sees
the defense seizing the defensive with
both hands and look at him go he has
played the move Rook H H is is the best
move in the position we're being
informed the point is Knight F4 is still
very bad because of Rook G4 you have to
put it on F6 and then the best move in
the position is maybe somewhat
surprisingly ping the bishop on C6 not
King E7 uh because if we move the if
they move the bishop away from D7 we are
perhaps creating this idea of Knight D6
I like that6 Bishop C6 we're also
threatening D4 Bishop F3 and mate by the
way D4 takes Bishop F3 and mate along
the H so I assume King E2 happens pretty
much by force a Tempo and now you you
can and now if we want we can probably
play KN KN D6 yes Knight
D6 all right and then I will challenge
the hline let's say take on H1 play here
I'm going to be you can go even kn7 is
very playable here I'm going to be angry
with myself why did I challenge the
hline and invite the move d4 you know
oops I've uh blundered a Tempo against
my Rook which means from this position I
should be challenging the G file Rook to
G1 96 first oh pardon me yes of course
Knight D6 for oops King E2 Knight D6
first Rook G1 yeah but on G1 you no
threatening check so I think I will take
on G1 I will take on G1 and play Knight
E4 and I think I'm fine uh Knight E4
yeah take on G1 go Knight D4 yeah you're
not worried about a potentially bad
Bishop versus good knight scenario I
have I think I have runners in the
center so I think I'm okay yeah so
Bishop takes I take with the D Pawn the
D Pawn Yeah yeah and I want to play F4
Rook H3 and so on I think I have like
legitimate count to play that's fa well
kn6 that was the only move and we
expecting Bishop C6 Bishop C6 extremely
precise play by the way on these by both
of them very very low time there's a
reason why all of our games have been
drawn it's because these guys play
really really good chess and very
precise chess as well Bishop C6
reiterate that uh Bishop C6 does have
some met Venom that there are ideas of
D4 and Bishop F3 locking in the king so
King E2 forced yep uh Knight D6 and I'm
just wondering if I'm if I'm right or
wrong about uh this if I'm wrong about
the move Knight E4 like I I could
potentially prevent it with the move F
Knight E7 no Knight D6 maybe he's
threatening to go Knight to
G8 well dislodged that Knight I
understand about the idea of
uh trading off the KN but are you really
happy about the resulting Bishop ending
position I mean it's not like that
Bishop I mean I appreciate that the the
chances of Defending and holding the
position a really high it's just not a
joy I understand yeah I I I have a
feeling that perhaps ler uh realized
that after Knight D6 there is no mo of
Knight takes D5 and decided not to
invest instigate further and it's a kind
of a line which if he had more time he
would maybe continue analyzing and life
uh so uh we're back to wanting to trade
off one of the Rooks and again I'm a
little bit UNC uh I'm not certain should
I be challenging The Rook on G1 or The
Rook on H1 for me I'd like the H file
because it's a little bit further from
black king So Rook H1 and
again uh give me your assessments after
say Rook H6 would you say I think should
be around equal because the black Rook
uh I think very likely will land on H3
and this will generate enough counter
play and Rook H6 also creates the very
important G6 Square for the Knight so
what I yeah your structure will actually
be under some pressure after the Rooks
get traded off right so I was thinking
not necessarily to go for The Rook G8
but the Knight G6 and as you said smoke
out the Knight on F6 by undermining and
if I'm and there we have it H1 played
yeah we're expecting Rook 6 H6 because I
think trading on H1 helps white that's
very very quite a bit Yeah black
definitely wants the move Knight
G6 uh
hitting uh E5 I feels like I'm like a
Tempo or so away Joy if I could get my
grippers my positional grip on the
position with moves like F4 and I don't
know King E3 and you know I'd be doing
great six played but it's like lanir
just each moment has his I think I think
that's exactly right I think uh White is
maybe one tempo away from completely
consolidating and uh uh and being firmly
in control but it's it's this Tempo is
just not
coming know we could see something like
Rook H6 Rook H6 let's say F4 right n G6
Rook F1 right
and the the F Pawn Will Will Survive but
I think black has clearly enough
compensation well countable compensation
you can go Rook H4 Rook H3 Rook H Rook
H2 forever right you can also go Rook H2
Rook B2 which I guess leads to a sharper
position but might also uh give white
some some hopes feels feels like uh
lanir having made the time control uh
very much relieved and he's got a solid
position I mean the the Knight on F6
pretty as a picture but not necessar
necessarily a very effective Knight no
uh we'd almost like the Knight on G5
that we'd probably much prefer the
Knight on D4 uh we would at least be
targeting the pawn on E6 somehow it just
doesn't quite work because I mean I'm
visualizing maybe the white king can
kind of run in and try to get into C5
but
yeah but
uh okay as we've uh reached home control
uh we're going to keep uh this in Focus
we've got this one gam wiing but let's
jump straight to Anastasia who was there
with the
guest I'm here with Wesley so the hero
of the tournament and the leader of the
tournament right now yes Wesley
congratulations first decisive result we
have when you managed to win the game it
all started with Queens indan when you
saw it on the board did you sorry King
IND not Queen
Gambit well were you happy to see it on
the board when Rich decided to go for it
yeah first of all I'm very pleased with
the win I mean it feels like a decade
since I last won a game yeah like so I
want to say glory to to Christ for for
that because all WIS come from him and
uh
yeah yeah it's a good feeling yeah yeah
for sure I mean I you know I mean I
think the world is getting crazy
nowadays with war and sickness
everywhere so I'm kind of actually not
100% focused on chess even in this
tournament because I'm like following
all the news about Russia Ukraine also
by Israel but I'm glad I can still win a
game
like and Richard is a great opponent as
I said earlier he's a great player two
years ago in the singfield cup he played
really well I think one of his best
tournaments where he was fighting for
first place up to the very last on I
believe
so um yeah it's nice to to finally win a
game he's also very creative player yes
and probably today he just wanted to
show that he's ready for fight yeah I
was going to say I didn't really prepare
actually at all for today because
yesterday was Thanksgiving yes exactly
we had a dinner and I think you were at
the table sitting together with Richard
with Richard yeah I'm I mean I'm in very
good terms with Richard and his wife
Javan I see them a lot also we in Europe
we played the tournament recently in
Berlin a blitz tournament and uh we're
in really good terms I mean I think he's
a he's a great guy he's got a great wife
so uh uh yeah but uh recently I think
he's been playing also nonstop like he
played isop man and then he played in
the European team so I don't know how he
just traveled all this way is here 25
hours yeah I don't know how players like
him or others or Fabby Fabby has played
non-stop for two months I don't know how
they do it but for me I I kind of need
like a two we break after every major
tournament just to re regenerate but uh
you know F but they're doing it so um
yeah I was very surprised by the king's
engan like I said I didn't prepare at
all so I just thought I'd play one C4
see what happens I actually haven't
played 1 C4 in quite a bit in classical
games so he spent over 2 minutes here
thinking like of course black has many
good replies I thought he would go for
like Bishop B4 stuff or something like
that like E5 is incredibly solid but
thought for a while and went for the
king's Indian like I didn't expect the
Kings Indian because it takes a lot of
courage to play it in a classical game
uh and so shout out to him
but I decided just if he was going to
play Kings and I'll play the famish
because I like I've been playing Knight
F3 and Bishop E2 like Al and I had a big
Blitz match on on the Kings indan just a
couple months back online so I was
getting much better positions but he was
he kept beating me every game so I said
okay like let's change this something
yeah so I thought I'd play F3 and also
it's more solid because you you still
you have options Castle Queen side so in
the worst case I won't get checkmated on
the king side hopefully but I haven't
played the smish in like seven years I
believe or something like that and then
yeah I thought C5 was the best but I
didn't know exactly what Richard was
going to play like I think C5 is very
very solid now after B should E Knight
C6 or I think Maxim plays C5 here but
here like D5 B6 and you know white is
not better but it's just very complex I
play Bishop D7 quickly and I figured
he's probably prepared against the main
lines with Knight C1 or Rook
C1 so played Rook B1 actually shout out
to my boy and
Tang because uh I was working with him
actually 9 years ago mhm back in
2014 and uh Rook B1 was a his idea I
remember very clear clearly but wow
something what you just analyzed 9 years
ago to your mind yeah well actually he
showed it to me I I don't think he
remembered it now like I don't think he
even remembers how
to about that session but I think Rook
B8 like usually Rook C1 is the move but
I think he played Rook B1 against me but
think he much more effective against
Rook B8 because like here for example
the rookies
passive on the B8 but when Play Bishop
D7 I thought I'll play Rook B1 anyway
just to surprise
Richie but I think H5 I think he still
prepared this it looks so ugly okay I
don't know if H5 is his preparation he
just he SP he play it quickly yes yeah
he probably spent like six minutes mhm
something like that but uh it looks very
ugly but uh I couldn't it's like it
gives you all this time to play whatever
you want on the queen side yes my my
four connected pawns or five yeah or
actually like seven
yeah I mean B4 C4 D4 E4 is very
impressive so I mean I could never play
like this with the black because doesn't
fit my style yes like you got all this
space yaser was very happy about it yeah
I probably yeah I probably would and
because he plays the English with white
so mhm I mean it takes certain kinds of
players to play the Kings Indian I don't
know where Richie went wrong maybe it's
just slightly worse the entire game okay
Bishop takes but my first attention was
Castle but of course I missed Bishop E8
and then I realized that was his plan
all along C4 Pawn mhm and I got Knight
C6 so I spent a long time here but I
also noticed he was getting low on the
clock so I I play Rook C1 I guess white
is slightly
better what do you think was the
critical moment let's I'm sure there
were a few but let's maybe move to the
to one of those well the first critical
moment was the king's indan then of
course when I played Rook B1 to surpr
yes okay and then I don't know I don't
see how he could have equalize for the
game I mean yeah it's it seems like yeah
I mean you got really good position and
he had to find a way yes to equalize and
maybe just didn't happen yeah maybe here
I mean maybe B5 in the computer doesn't
like B5 I suggest suggest F5 I don't
know maybe
here and something like that and then
get he gets counterplay with Queen E8
something uhhuh maybe may maybe here
like I wasn't especially pleased with
Knight D1 because you're retreating the
Knight but I didn't see any other option
I was going to play here but then the
Knight seems funny on F4 yeah in fact
this is this is very bad yeah so I mean
fortunately I choose the right Square
finally yeah yeah yeah when do you
understand the position is better for
you like you really like felt that yeah
mean it's close to that you have a huge
Advantage already well here I thought I
was slightly better and I was really
maybe Queen C7 Queen B8 not suggested by
the engine maybe this was his best
chance mhm and he's just slightly just
to bring one more piece to the queen
side and and he's just slightly worse
but at the same time that he has to
spend a further Tempo bring the Knight
back to F6 I see so I was really
surprised when he played E5 mhm no I I
was surprised by many of his moves H5
E5 I guess here I have many attractive
options but I couldn't find a way to
like I was sure I had a big Advantage
here like I could
take but then yeah man I don't know if
this
works C5 Rook d8 Castle Bishop
f8 Rook D1 Bishop C6 I was you were all
cating all these lines yes yeah and the
Knight looks Knight F7 oh my gosh what's
What's Happening Here Yeah I guess
Knight F7 is the only winning move yeah
I was looking at this but I didn't see
Knight F7 let's move to this moment when
yes I mean this is really interesting
land and probably was also better but
you remember somewhere here uh when he
when you yeah he exchange yes he decided
to go for this exchange sacrifice and he
played this queen H4 do you think that
he wanted to go like Queen H H3 after
and then he understood it doesn't give
him much maybe like Queen H3 here but he
went back I think he was just playing
for tricks at this point you know as his
as his style he's got very active style
like objectively he has to defend the
passive position yeah like mhm like uh
something like this yeah Queen D7 Rook
D1 like objectively maybe he had to
defend something like this but it's not
I don't think it's his style with a bad
Bishop exactly and then let's say the
game yeah we know what happened after
like you just kind of managed to use
your advant the huge Advantage you had
in was going to go F5 and then I wasn't
sure I was going to go something like
this yeah wow okay many many tricks and
check Wesley now actually like here I I
could I was thinking to play Knight A5
but I decided to be courageous once in
my life yeah so I decided to play Rook
C1 funny decided to be brave for once
and I couldn't really see what he was
playing for like uh I guess Queen H3
King F2 I thought he might go Knight F6
at least the queen
is but I guess like how was he been
thinking yes so wesle me it was a nice
game I mean finally you won you won it
you managed to win the game and like how
do you feel as a leader of the
tournament now well
question I mean I'm glad to win a game
you know finally I thought I would never
win a game again you like no this really
thank you so much Wesley and all the
best of luck for you in the next rounds
and now it's time to go for the
commercial break yes thank you thank
[Music]
you so wel welcome to grest tour first
of all and of course you're living in St
Louis but my question is when did you
come back and I know that you played in
some tournaments during this months uh
between the previous uh grandchester
event so how did what did you do last
month uh so uh I've played uh in a of
man um and I came back on uh November 8
I think on November 9 I I had a medical
exam
because Anie and I were applying for a
green card so I I got like six
vacines I'm still kind of I'm not sure
where I
am oh my God yeah um but you know it's
part of something that is required so
I'm happy you know to be become a
resident here so I
hope my green card will be granted and
uh you know things will be much easier
for me so you are still recovering from
this vaccination period of time yes so
what did you do after 9th of November
basically today we're on on 19th yes
20th yeah um well I prepared for a
tournament you know that's some
uh kind of
uh meetings you know with some friends
and we because we we left to to uh I
love man on the 19th of October and on
the 20th of October uh my daughter's
about she she turned one but we were not
here we had to kind of uh figure out
when we're going to do the birthday so
we did the birthday uh on the 18th and
all this preparation so yeah it's been a
busy but very pleasant time absolutely
it's nice that we still can say to our
kids this age that the birthday is not
the exact day yes it can be postponed
sometimes yes but I mean now that you
live in St Louis I mean in general how
does it feel to live at home here and
play I mean nearby and what impact has
the fact that St Lou Club is is also
located here oh it's very nice you know
uh I really love playing chest here so
far I I mean since I moved I haven't
really played well but uh I I'm a
fighter I always believed that every
single tournament is an opportunity you
know to improve my score so I look
forward to you know more tournaments in
St Louis where I can prove myself
absolutely you played in Poland as a
wild card of this Grand chest tour and
now you got also wild card for singfield
cup and how many times actually you
played in singfield cup and what let's
say place it has in your um chess life I
think I only missed one one year it was
the year when we were moving to St Louis
uh I was not supposed to play this year
but uh I got lucky you know to be a
replacement player for uh ding uh well I
mean the role that it plays
uh um I think you know uh generally to
be in The Grand Tour is is a goal for
every chess player I didn't make it last
year
and um of course it's uh it's not great
but uh at least it's a motivation it's a
motivation for me just to improve and
get to The Grand Tour and and play in in
my in my city absolutely and now that
you mentioned also Dink and the fact
that he's absent here um I was just
wondering I mean what is your opinion
about what is your opinion about all
these things which are happening in the
Chess World right now on the top
especially I mean with dink absence with
Magnus who doesn't want to play that
much in classic classical events um what
is your opinion about everything what is
happening let's say with a candidates
tournament I think the time is slowly
coming to a
point where uh it's difficult to play
classical chess because uh the the
openings uh and um the fact that neural
networks became a part of the chess and
and made uh starting chest so much
easier I mean it's very difficult to get
a game playing with white uh and
therefore I think we're almost reaching
the time that I've been waiting for my
whole career when we switch to CH 960 so
I think Magnus is ready I think almost
everybody is ready for it really this is
what you think is happening just yeah
yeah
it's I mean it's uh it's not much fun I
think uh because of the openings you
know I understand that it might be a a
difficult um information you know for
majority of amateurs because for them
there is a lot of uh still as as they
will say a lot of meat on the bone but
uh for professionals uh just showing
that uh you're a better player to uh uh
an average Grandmaster is already
very very difficult you have to kind of
hope for uh as they would say in tennis
unforce error because if you play uh
your best and I mean your opponent knows
the opening there is just no chance for
you to win the game yeah maybe this
something like this happened in Al of
men where you had good chances also and
then you played Four draws in the last
rounds like I paid attention like maybe
something like this happened there I
didn't go into details but yeah
generally that's that's a problem
because uh the positions that you get
from the opening uh I mean you you dream
of getting something that there is
playable you know there are actually
pieces on the
board so it's it's a bit of a problem I
I maybe people will think I'm
pessimistic I can tell you A lot of my
colleagues will think I'm actually
optimistic so what in 10 years we'll
have sful cup with 960 oh I hope I can't
wait yeah yes so this is where you see
yourself in 10 years I hope I I will be
fighting you know I you know it all
depends on uh such factors as health but
so far I can't complain so uh you know I
I love to fight I love to learn from um
young players
and it's just very interesting thing to
do yeah now speaking about the young
players who do you think are the most
interesting player now in the Chess
World I mean from Young
Generation Um there are just way too
many I think nowadays you can take uh
the whole um national Indian team and
you'll have all different personalities
but I personally I root for uh Arjun I I
wrote for arjin arasi in every single
tournament cuz uh it's
I think he has some sort of a funny
mannerism during the game you know he's
so relaxed that I just love seeing that
you know how relaxed is yeah it's it's
really hard to to look relaxed during
the chess game and actually to feel
relaxed as well yes and now that the
tournament is starting tomorrow
singfield cup like um are you looking
forward and let's say like last words
before the tournament and whom are you
like really want to play against well I
always look forward to be playing
tournaments
uh and especially strong tournaments
like this
one uh and well I think Fabby has been
playing tremendously so I I like playing
against him a lot I mean he uh really um
showing I mean a lot of improvement as
as a player because he works a lot on
chess and uh he finds new things and so
I would say Fabby Anish are my favorites
uh you know to to watch and learn from
thank you so much Leon and all the best
of luck in the
[Music]
tournament welcome back and uh during
the break well we did see a final result
it was a draw and there you can see the
players analyzing Ali Resa fua against
lenia Dominguez very closely contested
game it was a razor sharp actually and I
think a lot of the tactics and ideas
will remain behind the the curtain there
but I just feel that somehow Ali Raz are
left more on the table than lineer maybe
certainly certainly I I don't think
apart from that one moment early on
which honestly was a bit mystifying
while ler has not played E5 when he
could have right but from the moment he
hasn't uh alza was pretty much in
control for the rest of the game and had
very decent winning chances at certain
points in mutual time trouble but it
always remained a very complicated
position to play and
eventually uh they it equalized and
after the time control we should
probably show how it ended but it was a
very logical conclusion very very
logical indeed we left it just actually
just here at the very end itself F2 F4
in anticipation of the fact that this
Pawn on E5 is going to need defending
Knight came to G6 attacking the pawn on
F4 it was defended Rook H4 gift me the
pawn on on F4 King E3 check now
unfortunately we can't even think about
putting the rook in the way oops that
Bishop on C6 uh lives with purpose we
would say D4 check and there goes the
Rook so Ali Resa did play King D4 and
then there was just a a very forced and
I would say correct repetition and the
players agreed to a draw but I can't
believe it we have a leader we do now
have a leader I mean it took four rounds
but we do have a decisive game between
Wesley so and Richard reports and at a
moment there it might have been three
there was three games
because if he could have gotten that
Bishop D5 move in at certain points
during the round I think all four games
were very much in play and VL missed
what amounts to almost a assured win
with one move in one move only but there
was a certain point in the game where he
was much
better and uh and here's our uh poll if
you will which game will end decisively
well I must tip my hat uh to uh to VAR
because he's just such a brilliant
insightful person yes you also guess
correctly you're just saying that cuz
it's so
true but it was nonetheless a good guess
that it was a decisive result between
thank you for competing and thank you
for competing for participating I mean
you're welcome and it does mean after
four rounds we have a leader in the
competition wle so is in outright first
after scoring a victory over Richard
report he moves to two and a half points
out of four and in second place well we
have whole load of people who have drawn
all their games and there at the bottom
we see see Richard reports with one
point after suffering his first loss
absolutely
um actually there was a moment Peter I
wanted to bring your it was this moment
where we had I think it was right here
yeah we didn't have enough time to
properly discuss the move Knight H4
which is Def yeah definitely a very
important moment Knight H4 and black can
can even play Bishop B5 check here so I
can understand why ala wanted to begin
by Bishop D3 because Bishop D3
absolutely safeguards his own King but
the complications which begin with
either Bishop B5 check first or Rook G1
check first and then Bishop B5 appear to
come out fine for white and that means
that let's say we imagine Rook G1 King
E2 Rook E1 King E1 uh without the Rook
on G6 the black king suddenly starts
feeling a lot more vulnerable with ideas
of Queen H6 check and Knight F6 or even
the immediate Knight of6 Knight of6 has
my attention that's a nasty for uh this
would have been very very uh challenging
I think to play for black on very very
short time but and the other point is
that the move Knight H4 doesn't give
black the tempo he needs to play Knight
because uh uh of Queen H6 but you said
Bishop B5 check might have been
offputting I I saw some lines once again
there was there was no real time to
check but I I have a feeling he didn't
play Knight H4 because he was worried he
will miscalculate something here Bishop
B5 I think the the issue here is that
ab5 isn't even forced you can actually
play C3 C4 wow and postpone the capture
of that of that Bishop until that time
that you completely collect everything
on the on on on the king side uh the
lines get messy but they do appear to
come out trumps for uh for white gotta
but I think both of them were in about 2
minutes at that point right and allowing
these types of complications when
optically optically it feels like white
is still much better after Bishop D3 I
think right you can understand that
there as a decision here but Bishop D3
Knight C8 and then that initiative
however slight it was kind of petered
out absolutely and uh ler played very
very precisely from that moment onwards
actually he he made I think every single
best move well it's again one of those
things JY it was just like just that one
moment there was the window right there
night four in the nvl game there was
that window that one moment Bishop D5
you miss it it's gone it is gone I mean
that's why these players are the best
chess players in the world and they're
incredibly resourceful full of grit and
resilience very impressive game actually
I would say from both parties I felt
like the opening was perhaps Advantage
lenyard right but then the middle game
SW in Fu's favor but in the
end great great uh result there great
encounter and let's go over to the
studio with Anastasia and a special
guest yeah I have ala with me ala
welcome to the show let's check what
happened in this game I think you came
very close at one point probably to
winning I don't know what was your
feeling during the game yeah I think it
should have been I think much better at
least so I think that was the first
critical moment you played this Knight
G5 and after H6 you came back probably I
thought that you had some ideas maybe to
play after H6 I don't know Knight F7 or
yeah I saw this line and I didn't
believe I have I'm playing for anything
mhm I saw after Queen H4 I couldn't find
anything yeah so I just went back to
play game so probably doesn't matter
yest yeah yeah it's a very typical
London
position um here we were playing normal
moves and I think he was too slow he
should have gone f65 faster or F5 F4 mhm
so so here he played like this I felt
like I have good position after
H4 but yeah he played Rook E8 H5 takes
Bishop
B1 this is very good position because
his King is very weak and I have always
Queen C2 so so you you would provoke F5
later right M yeah Queen I think here I
came closest to
winning but I couldn't find the mate the
winning oh yeah I
missed h i missed Bishop of five here ah
Bishop of five yes yeah I missed this
takes
takes and if Queen Rook a seven yes and
if
Knight yeah takes
takes oh yeah and in the end you yeah
this is very good yeah so where did you
stop calculating at which point well you
didn't see que I didn't see Bishop
Bishop of five I see tell this what is
happening
here
G6 takes okay this is
me yeah I missed Bishop five okay but
there were also some other moments let's
let's get yeah let's check I mean the
game was long with so many opportunities
for both F five
MH became a little bit tricky somewhere
here yeah I
couldn't yeah I couldn't find the good
moves yeah but I think que D2 was
logical let's not check that much the
engine I mean which other moves like
Queen you allowed all this Rook G2 and I
said I have to here 94 right did you
check the move night4 yeah I was yeah I
checked night H4 briefly and so what
what did you calculate here like or you
didn't like this Rook G1 Rook E1 I
calculated things like mhm I first of
Bishop B5 check was in my mind oh Bishop
that's why you played Bishop D C4 only
move w wow H so what happens if you if
you take C4 yeah I missed C4 because
takes takes this yes this I said I'm
losing or or it's dangerous this I I
refuseed oh but this is clever I could
go C4 ah C4 here yeah because I will not
allow the and queen yes yeah Queen is
not on B5 yes yeah these are missed okay
but it's it's hard also to Queen H6 King
F7 check and then I take ah you take
after yes those still not easy no
nothing is easier it seems like in this
game yeah here he found I see it only
mhm yeah and then I felt like he could
play for advant yeah he's minus one yeah
you started to feel that it's getting
better it's getting really out of hand
here but um I couldn't find
97 in this moments let's say when you
start feeling this like what do what do
you tell to yourself like okay like just
calm down you know come back to the game
what yeah I just wanted to bail out
somehow but yeah this move after I'm
very because I exchanged one pair of
rook and then I could defend somehow but
with two Rooks yeah this is
annoying yeah but still I have chances
to hold so thow was good result for him
I think the end maybe also for both of
me it's just crazy I mean do you have
this eager to win the game in this
tournament like what's happening with
you watching all those draws around you
and in your games yeah it's
very um it's not good I'm making all
these draws I normally don't make these
draws I know yes of course you're you're
also a fighter yes but it's at the end
always getting draws I don't know what
to do but I was winning this game so
it's good start I think and absolutely
and I wish you all the best in the next
rounds ala thank you for coming and
sharing your thoughts we're going to
back to the studio to Y and Jo P thank
you Ali Raa thank you Anastasia and uh
yeah the bishop B5 check if you don't
see C4 the opportunity just passes you
right by right there asie Resa said
there you know it was very tempting to
go porn takes bishop and calculate those
lines and of course those ones were very
wild and uh here we can see it is our
prediction time so
well has anyone chosen Wesley uh no all
I can say is I was robbed I mean Bishop
D5 and we are having a conversation yes
well when it comes to topic of Wesley
what about what about what about my guy
not winning a position in which every
legal move wins that was from the one he
that was that that that was rough uh
final standings after uh round four and
it does mean that it was a great day for
tournament leader Wesley so who defeated
Richard report he also now moves within
five points in the live ratings yes the
rating Al res fuia remember the rating
spot for the candidate is up grabs and
second place we have Fabiano kirana Ali
R fuja and a whole bunch of players and
Richard report now is in ninth place
after his loss so it was a great day of
Chess in the end it was full of fight
final thoughts about round four uh Peter
I honestly think that we were all of us
were somewhat robbed today because we we
could have easily had three or maybe
even four decisive results if if you
take specific moments in every single
game it's really weird to say that about
a game which featured a peace sacrifice
but the most peaceful was maybe the game
between Fabi and Yan and even that
wasn't a boring game by any stretch and
in in the other three there were
definitely spots along the way where a
player would feel grieved not to have
won that position so the tournament I
think is warming up nicely we're we're
running out of time a little bit but uh
uh we're getting there we're getting
there today is an optimistic day for in
terms of the future of our tournament I
enjoyed it greatly me too the blockade
has been lifted uh no more the draw
virus has stopped uh we're going to be
coming back tomorrow for round five
before we enjoy our free day on a Sunday
right free day on a Sunday but until
then we do have an amazing day of Chess
tomorrow so tune in same time same place
and thank you everyone for watching
you're not going to want to miss
tomorrow's action absolutely good night
good
[Music]
night
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
prohibited